good morning sir johnny thank you
now
i'm going to ask mary to invite you to
take the oath
but before i do that let me just explain
to you what the
setup is
uh you're talking not just to uh the
room in front of you
uh and around you with which there are
over 150 people
but in particular beyond this room
you will be talking
through the mediums of live stream and
youtube
to an audience out there
which i suspect today will number uh in
in the hundreds
so that's your
audience
uh and there's those people to whom you
are talking
miss richards will ask you the questions
in a moment or two but first as i say
mary would you please administer the
oath
you may sit or stand as you please
please take the book in your raised hand
and repeat after me
i swear by almighty god i swear by
almighty god that the evidence i shall
give and the evidence i shall give shall
be the truth shall be the truth the
whole truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth nothing about the truth
so john i'm just going to start with a
brief overview of your political career
you first became an mp in 1979 is that
correct that's correct
and then your first ministerial post was
at the department of health and social
security you were parliamentary under
secretary of state from september 1985
to september 1986
and then minister of state from
september 1986 to june 1987. correct
now is it right to understand that in
both those roles parliamentary under
secretary and minister of state you were
concerned with the social security
rather than the health side of the
department that's correct the department
was uh divided eventually it was split
of course but at the time there was one
department but there were two quite
distinct areas health and social
security
on uh social security on one side and
health on the other and i was
exclusively both as
the parliamentary secretary and the
minister of state for the disabled
i was on the social security side
so i saw no health documents at all at
that time
um we've heard from other witnesses that
there would be
weekly meetings with the secretary of
state who i think at that time was
norman fowler um did those involve both
the health ministers and the social
security ministers yes they did
and do you have any recollection of
those meetings discussing either hiv
or the position of those who had been
infected through blood or blood products
well i dare say they must have done but
i have no recollection of them 30 odd
years later
now
your ministerial career then moved to
the treasury between june 1987 and july
1989 you were chief secretary to the
treasury i was
you were then foreign secretary for a
pretty short period of time july 89 to
october 89. why was that so short-lived
well it was rather short-lived because
mr lawson fell out with mrs thatcher
and resigned and the prime minister
needed a new chancellor
so to my regret i was moved very rapidly
from the foreign office to the treasury
and so you were chancellor of the
exchequer from october 1989 to the 28th
of november 1990
and then you became prime minister
november 1990 a position you remained in
until may 1997. that is correct
and you continued to be an mp until the
may 2001 elections is that right i did
now i'm just so that those
listening can understand the structure
of your evidence i'm going to ask you
first of all some general questions
about
decision making in relation to
government expenditure
and your role at the both as chief
secretary to the treasury and chancellor
and i'm then going to ask you about
the decision-making in which you had
some involvement in terms of the
provision of financial assistance or
support or decisions not to provide
financial assistance and support
first of all
as chief secretary then as a chancellor
and then as prime minister and then i'll
have some general questions towards the
end
so starting if we may with your role and
responsibilities as chief secretary to
the treasury
what what in broad terms is is the
nature of that job and how does it
differ from the job of the chancellor of
the exchequer well the chancellor of
exchequer has responsibility for the
overall control of the treasury he's
responsible for macro policy
and in that time that would include
included the responsibilities the bank
of england now have of setting interest
rates but within that the chief
secretary who's also a junior member of
cabinet but subordinate to the
chancellor of course
the chief secretary is responsible for
the conduct of public expenditure
and what that means is that every autumn
there would be a public expenditure
round
and each department of state would
individually submit their bids
their wish list
for expenditure in the following year
and the chief secretary would have to
negotiate
what their expenditure actually was they
would be individual negotiations with
each and every secretary of state
on their own individual expenditure bids
how that would work within the treasury
was at first once the bids were
submitted
the treasury would look at them and
brief the chief secretary the chief
secretary would then meet alone with the
secretary of state for health or
education or defense whatever it may be
and would negotiate exactly what
happened
and although the
chief secretary is the junior member of
cabinet or was in the pecking order in
those days
he did have an extraordinary amount of
influence because he was able to move
expenditure about in those negotiations
and he was able to determine within
budgets
which were the areas of particular
importance now he didn't make that up
he had to pick that up from the bids
that were actually submitted by the
civil service and the minister in those
particular departments but it was a long
and arduous business and negotiating
public expenditure i'm not sure it's
done the same way today but that's how
it was done then
and of course from time to time there
would be disputes
the department might bid more than the
chief secretary felt was appropriate
and where there were disputes the
meeting would probably or meetings
plural would probably break up and they
would reassemble
if it was completely impossible to reach
a
conclusion a satisfactory conclusion to
both the chief secretary
and the spending minister
then the matter would be referred to a
cabinet subcommittee loosely called the
star chamber
which would be chaired by a very senior
member of cabinet in those days it was
chaired by william whitelaw
who was the deputy prime minister
effectively in those days
and they would determine whether to
agree with the chief secretary or with
the spending minister
or striker compromise and that would be
a settled part of public expenditure
and the chief secretary
worked within a remit
the chancellor and the cabinet would
have agreed a total of overall
expenditure that was appropriate for the
macro economy the amount we could afford
without dramatically changing taxation
and so he didn't have a completely free
hand
he had to bring in the public
expenditure round within the limits of
expenditure set by the chancellor
and approved by the cabinet
so that is the basis of of how it worked
it was a very long and arduous business
and
often led to some disputes but mostly
mostly not invariably they were settled
without reference to the cabinet
subcommittee
i'm just going to ask you to look at a
passage in from your autobiography which
describes this process
um lawrence it's rnit0001628
and it should be the third page
we can pick it up at the top of the page
you say the chief secretary this is the
third line has one of the lowest
profiles of any cabinet minister but
this is deceptive but he is the most
influential minister in determining the
division of the total of public spending
who gets what
this gives him the power if he wishes to
facilitate new policies or to hold them
back thus although the most junior
member of the cabinet the chief
secretary has an authority far greater
than the casual observer ever realizes
and then if we skip over the next
paragraph please lawrence and go down
just over halfway down the page
the most important part of the chief
secretary's year is the public
expenditure survey
which begins in the summer when each
secretary of state puts in a bid for his
department's financing for the next
three years is this the process you were
just describing exactly so
these bids set out the ambitions of the
department for the years ahead rather as
the black widow spider dances and odd
quadrille with its partner before
finally mating the public spending round
has its own rituals
the bids often contain an unrealistic
wish list and are invariably padded so
that the minister can be seen to make
concessions in head-to-head negotiation
with the treasury
now that might suggest that as as chief
secretary
uh you would potentially approach the
bid with a degree of skepticism is that
right
i'm not trying to use the word
skepticism but
any spending minister will put in bids
larger than he expects to be approved
because he knows in negotiations if he
makes concessions in some area he's more
likely to get exactly what he wishes in
another area and also you would find
typically let's assume the cabinet had
set a remit of x for the sum total of
all the public expenditure
routinely when the bids were submitted
they would come to x plus a very great
deal they might even come to 2x
and so there was a huge amount
to be taken out of the public
expenditure bids
in order to meet the demands of what the
economy can afford without rapidly
rising taxation or rapidly increasing
borrowing
and of course in that particular period
in the 80s and the 90s of course
we were in a period of great economic
difficulty
we were facing high levels of
unemployment
we were facing very high levels of
inflation
and it was necessary to deal with those
the problem manifested itself a little
more seriously a little later than 87 in
89 and 90 it was a much more serious
position but even then there was a real
concern with inflation
it had been
a bug bear for governments
since the 1960s
and whatever successive governments
conservative labor whatever they had
been had tried to do
it had been devilishly difficult to get
inflation down and keep it down
and government after government had
failed actually to do so
and so inflation was the big bug bear
that had affected expenditure right the
way through
30 40 or so years and it wasn't until
90s and the sheer pain of policies in
the 90s including the exchange rate
mechanism that actually got inflation
down for a low period where it stayed
subsequently for about 30 years
does does that mean that given the
economic background you describe and the
role of the chief secretary that the
chief secretary would be a kind of
inverted mr micawber always looking for
something to turn down effectively
well mr mccover was always waiting for
something to turn up
but um
not really the job at the chief
secretary is not to be an abominable no
man that is emphatically not his role
it's not only an economic role it's a
political role
and
the chief secretary would have to be
political
he has to reduce bids
that are not of prime concern he has to
do that in order to make sure you can
fund the things that really are
important so he's not an abominable no
man but where he sees a bid that plainly
is unnecessary or prevents money being
provided for something that is more
necessary is likely to say no to it but
when he finds something that is
desirable
it is uh usually the case that he will
accept the bid now he may not set the
entirety of the bid
because the other element of this
is to make sure that the money can
actually be spent within the financial
year
in those days the public expenditure
round covered one year only effectively
uh the principal bit was one year only
and so the chief secretary would wish to
ensure
that the bids weren't padded to go into
a second year
because if that happens in the
department of education then you're
having to cut down in the department of
social security
so there is a good deal more sub
complexities in the public expenditure
round than i immediately explained all
that i set out in the extract from my
biography and how does the chief exec
the chief secretary then
decide what what is more important what
what does merit funding and what does
not
precedent
necessity
um
changing circumstances
he'll sometimes take account of
something he knows is coming down the
road that will occur in the middle of
the year but hasn't yet occurred
and of course
because it's impossible to forecast all
these things
the chief secretary and the treasury
would set a contingency found as well
the contingency fund is more an art form
than a science
you gather together what you think might
happen that is unexpected and unforeseen
and what it might cost
and it's very much an assessment there's
no scientific process in that
but it does give you a contingency fund
so that if something occurs in mid-year
that could not have been foreseen or is
more expensive than was foreseen there
is a contingency fund to which the
department can turn via that approach
the chief secretary and ask for more
money and is the contingency fund a
general one or are there specifically no
it's a general contingency fund
let us suppose you were the secretary of
state for health
and in the middle of the year a new
health crisis arose that you hadn't
foreseen and nobody else had foreseen
if that involved expenditure you would
come to the chief secretary let us
assume it was me and ask for more money
the first thing i would do would be to
look at your budgets
and see if you were under spending in
some of the areas we had agreed at the
previous expenditure round to see
whether there was a bulk of money in
your budget that could be moved to meet
that contingency
and if there wasn't
and more often there isn't than there is
if there wasn't i would then
discuss with you the size of contingency
funding you needed
and i would uh i would agree that
and uh that would be the end of the
matter you would have the money
so in terms of the the the annual bids
you've described um a process that if if
there was
uh
disagreement it could go to this star
chamber this this cabinet or ministerial
subcommittee what about the contingency
reserve typically if if there was a
disagreement they could either go to the
deputy prime minister william white law
who would probably reassemble the
committee or you could appeal directly
to the prime minister
you could do either
um and if there's a principal point i'm
sure you'll come to this later but one
of the principal jobs of the prime
minister
is actually to determine
and and and settle disagreements between
ministers
upon expenditure or policy matters
and so the process you've described
is this right you wouldn't expect it to
go to the prime minister
unless there was a disagreement that
couldn't otherwise be resolved if there
wasn't a disagreement the chief
secretary would agree it
and uh i cannot i cannot think of a
single occasion
in which i agreed a contingency
expenditure
when it didn't go through without any
difficulty at all i mean the chancellor
might look at it and raise an eyebrow
but i can't think of a single time when
anybody
uh objected to a contingency agreement
that had been made
and
typically
how much information would
a department supply to the treasury
i'm talking now about the general
process not the contingency applications
or requests
how much information would it supply to
the treasury for the chief secretary to
to take his or her decision oh they well
they'd supply a certain amount of
information here is the problem they
would say this is how we think it will
work out this is the money we think is
going to be necessary
the chief secretary would then ask
questions he would probably ask i mean
this doesn't happen for every tiny bit
of course or you'll be doing it all year
but for the significant areas the chief
secretary may well ask further questions
and when you come to talk to me ask me
later about some of the issues that
arise you will see that exactly that
thing happened
i paused on the expenditure because i
needed to ask a number of questions that
had not yet been answered by the
department
but in the end they got their money but
they did have to
provide the information that was
necessary to ensure it was value for
money the point about the chief
secretary really
um is is that he is
he is the barrier between
a total loss of control over expenditure
and the taxpayer having to pay for it
because it isn't the government's money
that is what people tend often to forget
it is the taxpayers money it is the
money of everybody in this room
and everybody as a brian said who may be
watching this morning it is their taxes
and the chief secretary is their defense
against unlimited expenditure
whilst we have this document on screen
could we go to two
uh two pages and further one please
lawrence
just want to pick it up towards the
bottom of the page
um just the last two paragraphs so you
say in the penultimate paragraph i tried
to reduce or eliminate bids
by challenging the case made for them by
the ministers facing me although in
doing so i was always acutely aware that
they had to return to their departments
and defend the deal they had accepted
i always left them with what we in the
treasury called a lollipop even if we
denied many of their cherished schemes i
had no wish to undermine their
credibility or that of the government
just just pausing there what did you
mean there by by leaving them with a
lollipop
in almost every bit there's something
which if you were utterly rigorous you
would have been able to toss out
but the credibility of ministers in
their department is important
it's important to the conduct of
government generally and it's it's
important to them within their ministry
so occasionally you would see things
that you could if you wish to be utterly
ruthless have torn out of their
expenditure bid
and i chose not to do so
they weren't things that involved
hundreds of millions of pounds they
would have been relatively small things
but i was conscious
that the spending ministers had a
responsibility to their departments and
to their clients
and as i said
i'm not there but
i didn't see the role of chief secretary
to be an abominable no man
you you sometimes have to accept the
advice you're given so sometimes i was a
little more lenient in some areas where
i could perhaps if i wish to have been
tougher but
i'll enter this caveat that did depend
that i could see i was on track for
getting the sum total of public
expenditure within the ceiling
set by the cabinet
um and
to what extent would um departments
effectively be um
bidding bidding against each other or
trade-offs oh absolutely they're
absolutely beating against each other
they don't see it that way i mean each
individual department would look at what
that department felt it needed
now every department would have had
ambitions
that would have been too expensive for
the taxpayer to meet
so those ambitions had to be delayed or
paired back
so in essence
to take the example i gave earlier if if
the sum total of public expenditure be
permitted by the government that the
country could afford was x
and the bids were 2x
then you had to you had to pay things
down
and that was the uh the job of the of
the chief secretary so every department
was in a sense in competition with other
departments it may be that one
department well for example if you take
the recent covid uh outbreak plainly the
department of health needed more help
than other departments so within an
overall ceiling two things could have
happened
the contingency fund could have met
every addition
or alternatively if other departments
were under spending or if there was no
capacity for the contingency fund to
meet it
you could have pared down the budgets of
other departments
during the time when you were chief
secretary
did ministers come to you
in very different ways were there some
who would really fight their corner and
and try and get as much as possible and
others who would be much more relaxed
well i don't think any of them were very
relaxed
uh going to the treasury with an
expenditure bid is a is is quite a
business
um and the treasury would have been very
well briefed and they would have made
sure that i was very well briefed so it
wasn't easy there were some ministers
who were better at it than others
the territorial ministers were always
extremely tough
because a large part of their
expenditure was just automatically
reflected from the percentage
expenditure that is made for that
department in england
but other things were not
and they were fierce they fiercely
fought for those largely because they
were relatively small amounts
and also because
they knew at the end of the day when you
closed the public expenditure round you
weren't going to hold it up for the odd
million or so and they knew it and so
they were much less likely to concede
during discussion
the two most difficult ministers to
negotiate with
throughout the uh
years i was chief secretary uh were were
depart
were territorial secret secretaries of
state
and i just wanted to pick up what you
say in your
again in your autobiography about john
moore
uh secretary of state for health and
social security at that time so it's the
bottom of the page you say one tail
needs scotching
john moore who after the election had
become secretary of state for health and
social security and i was said to be
rivals and it was widely believed in
some quarters that i gave him a poor
settlement in order to damage his
political career
john was a former big over-the-page
treasury minister convinced of the
virtues of low spending and rather
exotically he tried to match his
policies to his philosophy
in pursuit of this admirable consistency
he bid for too little money in the
public expenditure settlement rather
than too much this concern for prudent
economics would cause him much
difficulty a rare and honest approach
that earned him a program um
could you just flesh that out a little
in the sense of your your reflection
that he would bid for too little
and that that would cause him difficulty
john had been a treasury minister
he was steeped in treasury at treasury
orthodoxy
he knew how important it was to keep
public the total of public expenditure
within the limits
that the country could afford or we
would be borrowing more and interest
rates might rise
or we would be uh or we would have to
raise taxes and he was
acutely concerned about that
and he looked beyond his own department
and felt himself instinctively that
every department ought to assist the
treasury in making sure you could keep
within the public expenditure levels
agreed by the cabinet
he was quite rare among cabinet
ministers in taking that view most of
them had looked at their department and
their direct responsibilities and bid
for the money to see whether or not they
could get it that i think is basic human
nature
and most of them did that john moore
didn't
in that he differed from the other
colleagues and so his bids were
sometimes on the on the low side and
indeed there were occasions in the
discussions with john moore when we
agreed to
move his bids around a bit so that in
some areas he got a little more than he
had initially asked for
and when you say that caused him much
difficulty was that because the the it
resulted in an underfunded department
well it was difficult it resulted in
difficulty for him
because there were things he could have
bid to do
but didn't bid to do
and when they popped up a little later
people said well why didn't the
secretary of state foresee this why
didn't he bid with him bid for it
and of course at the end of the day
uh
not in a single year but over a period
of years
you're only in a position to meet really
dire contingencies if your financial
accounts are in good order
john moore took that long long-term view
rather than the short-term view that i'm
as just that he must just see his
department through the next 12 months
um
can i then turn to your time as chief
secretary and some of the decisions in
which
you had a degree of involvement
i'm going to start with a letter
at september 1987. it's scgv
six zeroes
seven underscore zero five zero please
lawrence
um
we can see it's addressed to the prime
minister it's headed compensation for
hemophiliacs
and at the top there is a letter stamp
which reads secretary of state for
social services
and if we go to the next page
bottom of the page we can see it's dated
the 24th of september 1987
the signature's been
redacted but at the initials of jm
um
is that jmu
no
is it your understanding that that jm is
john moore it is john he was the
secretary of state for social services
it was interpreted as being me
in a widely read tabloid
who produced several pages some years
later of how i had personally tried to
persuade the prime minister not to be
helpful on the subject of
people suffering from
blood infection but it emphatically was
not my letter
um if we then just look at the content
of it because it was copied to you and
it really helps us i think pick up the
decision-making process
so the first paragraph explains i'm
writing to let you know
how i intend to handle the issue of
compensation for hemophiliacs with the
hiv virus and the media campaign which
will be launched shortly on their behalf
by the hemophilia society of great
britain
and the next paragraph then explains in
the first line that the campaign will be
emotive and highly charged we will be
under considerable parliamentary and
public pressure after the press launch
of the campaign in early october and no
doubt the issue will be active during
our party conference
um there's then a a description of the
background in the next paragraph if we
go to the bottom of the page
mr moore says the question of government
compensation for this group was raised
specifically when norman fowler and tony
newton gave evidence earlier this year
to the social services select committee
whilst norman and tony made it quite
clear how much they sympathized the
government's position was that there has
never been a general
state scheme
to compensate those who suffer adverse
effects from medical treatment
compensation can only be awarded by the
courts if negligence is approved the
full range of social security benefits
are of course available to those
hemophiliacs who qualify
and then he says this i've looked at the
case for compensation again carefully in
the light of the impending campaign but
have concluded that the line taken by
the social services committee was right
any special arrangements for
compensation could cost a minimum of
three million pounds and could only be
funded at the expense of other
priorities moreover it's logically
difficult to distinguish the claim by
hemophiliacs from the claim of many
others damaged in the course of their
medical treatment and there's no doubt
that compensating hemophiliacs would
lead to pressure for many other groups
with similar treatment
and then he continues well all of us
must have every sympathy for
hemophiliacs who've been infected with
the hiv virus i do not feel it would be
wise to set a general precedent by
accepting that the government should
provide a special compensation scheme i
shall be taking steps to ensure that the
case for not giving compensation is well
understood by the media and by our own
supporters i am of course very ready to
discuss this issue with you if you so
wish
and then he explains he's copying this
minute to the law present secretaries of
state for wales northern ireland and
scotland the chief secretary and sir
robert armstrong so the chief secretary
at that point in time as you he was
um
now this wasn't a document that called
for any particular action or decision
by the prime minister or indeed by you
as chief secretary and
do you
as far as you can recall was this the
first time the question of compensation
um had been raised or brought to your
attention
well so far as i'm aware yes
um i see nothing on the letter when i
saw the original letter that indicated
whether i saw it or not i may well have
done i may well have seen it but there
is a lot of there are a lot of letters
that are copied to different departments
because at some stage
they may have to take a role
and so the earlier correspondence is
copied to them
seen by the
principal private secretary
but held for a future date in case they
are going to be needed by that
department so i certainly didn't take
any action on that i suspect probably
given its content that i did see it
i suspect that i did see it
and it soon became apparent
that that line of uh
no compensation no fault compensation to
use the jargon was one that was going to
be perfectly easy to hold in legal terms
but not at all easy to hold in moral
terms
and that is why as we will see
there was subsequently uh more
discussion more help as the scale of the
disaster became apparent
and we'll pick that up as we go through
the documents and just to
for the sake of completeness lawrence if
we have dhsc
zero zero zero four five four one
underscore one four one
we have a letter from number 10 dated
the 28th of september 1987
um which records um that the prime
minister who was of course at that time
mrs thatcher has seen and noted without
comment your secretary of state's minute
of the 24th of september and then we can
see that the letter in turn was copied
to to the same um recipients of the of
the first letter
and
now that's september 87 i want to pick
it up then in the next month
with a letter you received and i think
along with many other mps from the
hemophilia society it's at hsoc0004760
underscore zero zero one
um so this is the letter 12th of october
1987. it's from the reverend tanner who
was chairman of the hemophilia society
and this is a blank version in the sense
it's dear blank but we'll see from
subsequent letters that
you were one of
the recipients of it
and he says i'm writing to ask for your
support in our campaign to help the most
tragic victims of the aids crisis people
with hemophilia
and the second paragraph then describes
picking it up in the second line a large
number of people were infected as a
result of treatment by commercially
produced products mainly drawn from
blood donations given in the u.s and
third world
treatment from this source with the
attendant risks was required
because the uk was not and still is not
self-sufficient in blood products
despite of successive government
promises since 1977.
the letter then goes on to talk about
the effects on those who've been
infected we can see those listed i don't
propose to read them out
the reverend tanner explains 57 have
aids 41 have died
all of this in addition to having to
cope with a life-threatening disorder
hemophilia
the government is responsible for this
situation
all these people were infected as a
result of treatment through the nhs
and then he adds despite the house of
common social services committee
accepting that
calls for compensation for hemophiliacs
and others who become hiv positive as a
consequence of infected blood
transfusion and for special life
insurance arrangements for hemophiliacs
deserve careful consideration the
government has not as yet volunteered
any form of support financially or
otherwise at present they are hiding
behind the cloak of the courts in saying
that they are not liable for
compensation however there is a clear
moral case that the government should
provide recompense
and then he sets out further details in
that regard
and
now that
we we can see i think that you
undoubtedly received that letter from
hsoc
yes i did zero zero zero three five
eight four
um this is you writing is this correct
in in your capacity as mp rather than as
chief secretary to the treasury yes it
is and i'll explain why that was the
letter was sent to my constituency as a
constituency member of parliament
i suspect it was probably sent to a lot
of members of parliament
um members of parliament get a great
deal of letters that are circular i
don't know whether that was the case but
the fact that it was sent to me in my
constituency
rather than at the treasury
suggested it was part of the circulation
of letters to many people
rather than specifically to the chief
secretary
uh
i replied as a constituency mp
and we can see in the second paragraph
you say i fully appreciate the serious
nature of these that's a reference to
the problems faced by victims of
hemophilia and have noted carefully the
views which you express in your
colleague
expressing your letter i will do what i
can to bring these to the attention of
my colleagues in the government who have
special responsibility for health
matters
and then you explain you're unable to
attend a a meeting that have been
arranged at the house of commons um
what what would you have had in mind
when you said that you would do what you
could to bring the problems to the
attention of colleagues in government
well two things really
um personally it may help a little if i
explain the the correspondence process
if a member of parliament receives a
letter from their constituent
that relates to a specific problem
rather than a policy matter where a
reply would be straightforward
they would do one of two things they
would either see the minister but that's
not very popular because if every member
of parliament asked to see the minister
on every letter they had the ministers
would do nothing else
or he would write to the minister either
paraphrasing the concern
which was what i tended to do when i
wrote or attaching a copy of the letter
and asking the minister what the
government's policy was in order that we
could inform the constituent or the
person who had written to you exactly
what the policy was
if the policy was uh obnoxious or wrong
you might then see the minister and talk
to it now at this distance in time 35
years ago i have no constituency records
of
of my exchanges with constituents in
1987
perhaps unsurprisingly but i assume i
would have
written to john moore probably since we
were colleagues in cabin that i would
have spoken to him
most probably not in a formal meeting
but as we were in the lobbies voting
when you vote in the lobbies you go in
the eye lobby or the no lobby whichever
is appropriate
all the members of parliament are in
that lobby mill around it takes quite a
time to vote it's very old-fashioned
process
and you have the opportunity of talking
to your colleagues or ministers it's
highly probable
uh since john and i self-evidently chief
secretary and health secretary uh had a
lot to do with one another that i would
have discussed it with him then
um now if we just go over the page
the hemophilia society this time mr what
is the general secretary wrote back to
you
16th of october 1987 and the first
paragraph thank you for the letter um
and describe the letter in these terms
in which you express support for that
campaign which we've recently launched
to secure special provision for people
with hemophilia who become hiv antibody
positive through materials prescribed by
the nhs
i just want to ask you about something
in the letter that you then wrote back
to mr watters
it's hsac0003583
so 20th of october
you say this in the second paragraph i'm
afraid i must clarify one point um and
then you quote from the letter um uh
that have been sent by mr uh
that have been sent by you to mr tanner
and then you say this in the third
paragraph my letter was intended to show
my overall appreciation of the problems
of people who become hiv antibody
positive through materials prescribed by
the nhs and should not be interpreted as
support for the campaign which we have
recently launched i am sure you will
understand that as a government minister
i am precluded by convention from giving
specific supports to campaigns of this
nature although this does not of course
preclude me from discussing them with
colleagues on a confidential basis
what was the convention that precluded
you from expressing
positive or public support when you have
a letter like that you're essentially
asking the government to change its
policy
ministers just don't do that and remain
ministers it's just not the way one
behaves
in terms of private nature you may lobby
very hard for something but you don't
say you don't want to get any headlines
in the paper minister x attacks
government policy on why
so you you don't say that publicly what
i actually said to him at the time was
that i appreciated the serious
uh nature of the issue and indeed i did
because it was becoming more serious as
we shall see no doubt in a few moments
so i was very sympathetic and remained
sympathetic
but
until we had changed a policy
it was not appropriate for me as a
minister to indicate that and nor did i
um the point about no fault compensation
was always quite a sound point in terms
of precedent
what was a much less sound point
was the matter i referred to a moment
ago that there
there are times when
your instincts
override
what is existing policy and then you try
and change policy within government
because you are sympathetic to a
particular cause
now if i may say so john moore is no
longer with us
and the impression would have been given
by the earlier letter from john that you
quoted that he was unsympathetic i have
to tell you he wasn't
he wasn't unsympathetic he was he was
echoing the government's
effective line on the legality of the
issue
whilst discussing and wondering whether
something more should be done about it
as did his successes and as chief
secretary of course i was aware of what
they were thinking privately
but not saying
publicly
and the reason they did that of course
is because until they have all the facts
they don't want to inspire hope that is
not met
or create controversy
that is avoidable so it is a
a circumstance the system
that governments from the dawn of time
have actually operated until a change of
policy is privately uh agreed
now at that time
i replied to mr waters
and i i remember his letter because it
came so soon after the one from the
reverend uh tanner
i was sympathetic of the government's
position of the uh
position of the hemophilia society
and it was being discussed uh privately
john moore had said at one stage there
was not a good case for compensation for
reasons of precedent
he did not rule out nor
did he say he'd ruled out
conversation
in view of the circumstances of those
who were infected
and that is why his position seemed
rather hard line and it was a good deal
less hard line if i may speak belatedly
in his defense
than it immediately see it
immediately seemed
and pretty soon afterwards
if i recall
um
[Music]
tony newton
who i think was the minister of state
and john moore with due to meet the
hemophilia society
and
they had discussed that with me and with
others before they went
but only in broad outline they said that
they were going
um
there were many questions before they
went
that they weren't in a position to
answer
and so i advised them to be cautious
about those particular questions
because we wish to be sure of our facts
before any policy was changed
let's just pick up that correspondence
um
if we could have please lawrence
dhsc zero zero zero
two three seven five underscore zero one
zero
um now
this is
um
an undated letter but it's probably late
october um or early
november and because it refers to in the
first sentence a meeting on the 3rd of
november and this is 1987.
and the second paragraph picks up on on
john moore's minute of the 24th of
september the one that we looked at a
few minutes ago
and then the third paragraph says this
and you're absolutely right this is this
is from tony newton whilst john and i
still consider those arguments to be
intellectually valid
there is a powerful practical case for
recognizing the particular circumstances
of the infected hemophiliacs
this is reinforced by the society's
argument that those affected are a
clearly defined group whose numbers are
already determined there is also very
strong support for the society
particularly from our own supporters
inside and outside the house
in view of this we have concluded that
the line we have been taking is unlikely
to prove politically sustainable
and then if we just look further down um
we the next paragraph mr newton explains
we believe it would be
counter-productive to hold to our
present line when we see the hemophilia
society on tuesday we therefore propose
to respond more positively by saying the
government understood and sympathized
with the case that the society
were making we were therefore
considering how best we might respond
and we talked to them again when we
reached the decision
if you are content with this approach
and that you is the prime minister john
and i will discuss the options with
colleagues before a further meeting with
the society our aim will be to identify
an acceptable response which runs the
least risk of setting a precedent and
keeps direct government involvement to a
minimum we'll also have to consider how
the cost which is likely to be the order
of 5 million to 10 million should be met
i'm copying this minute to members of h
a
that i think is the cabinet subcommittee
on aids
um in anybody and you were a member of
h.a said this is a letter copied to you
now if we could just go further up the
page again a little please lawrence
charlie i
acknowledge sir john this isn't a letter
you authored but it's it's a letter you
saw
and
that the the reference in the third
paragraph is to the the powerful
practical case and and then in the last
sentence of that paragraph to the line
being unlikely to prove politically
sustainable
and
looking at looking at it now
what what do you think you would have
understood the the reasons being put
forward for for a change of position to
be
oh i think because it was becoming
apparent
how serious the issue was and how
widespread the issue was
and how unsustainable it would be for
the people who were suffering without
some form of practical compensation
we still didn't know the full scale of
what was going on but it was perfectly
apparent that it was a moving situation
and although it's not expressly
indicated in here i think the thought in
everyone's mind is that there will be a
movement now and there may well be a
movement at a later stage as as further
evidence becomes available
there's a rather
unattractive end to that paragraph when
it says it's unlikely to prove
politically sustainable
this is a letter from tony newton
i have to say tony newton would have
been much more concerned with the moral
case than the political and
sustainability of it
i don't know how many people
in this room may have known tony newton
but he wore his heart on his sleeve and
it was a very big heart indeed so he
would have been more concerned i think
about the moral case but he was seeking
to persuade ministerial colleagues that
politics demanded there was action
as well as
as well as the moral case that existed
but this was a moving situation and this
of course is addressed to the prime
minister yes
would that
perhaps suggest
a thinking or an understanding that the
prime minister might be more swayed by
the political argument than the moral
argument no i don't think so i mean i i
can quite see why one might think that
but this is of course was a letter
written to the prime minister
but circulated all sorts of other people
as well it was it was it was generally
aimed it wasn't a specific indication
that you had a hard-hearted prime
minister who was going to be beastly so
you've had to say it was all about
politics that that really wouldn't have
been what was in tony's mind
and what why
again i'm asking you about a letter you
received but didn't didn't
write but
it's a theme we might pick up with some
of the later documents as well
um politically
um sustainable or politically
unsustainable might suggest
coupled with the reference there to
there being strong support inside and
outside the house from our own
supporters that
this was the government
beginning to yield to
public pressure political pressure
rather than being swayed by a moral yes
it does give that impression i can see
that i can only tell you from with
within government of course pressure
from parliament in particular
uh is is a very real uh part of any
decision making that is certainly true
but i have to say to it wasn't the only
part of the decision making and it is
apparent from
the newton letters anyone who knows
newton
that
that it wouldn't possibly have been
but certainly there was very widespread
support
within parliament and and within the
governing party
for the position of the hemophiliacs
as the situation became better known i
mean if you look at the context of the
times i said earlier there was
a huge amount of economic uh problems
it was economic problems that were
dominant in parliament
but the
position of the hemophiliacs and what
had happened with blood was cutting into
that
it was becoming more understood in
parliament and more known in parliament
now parliament's often like a great
tanker
it takes a long time for something to to
to turn it round
and
i would certainly say in retrospect the
way opinion was building it was
beginning to turn around
but ministers aren't some different
breed who are
completely distracted and unaffected
by the same emotions
that affect backbench members of
parliament so it wasn't that the
government was just reacting to pressure
the government could see the case for
help
as well as the back benches
but it is much easier for a backbencher
to bang the table and said we must help
have help now
than a government that has to look at
the implications of providing help how
much help should there be
what would be the cost of that help in
terms of taking money away from other
people
how should you direct the help so it
goes into the best order over what
period should that help exist
should this help be
in addition to the
social security benefits that were
already being paid one doesn't forget
that the social security benefits were
already being paid to people who were
suffering but we were talking we were
beginning to talk here about amounts
over and above that
to go to the mcfarland trust as as would
be as would become
to be distributed to people with
hemophilia so there was
a good deal of sensitivity on both sides
both by the government at the time and
by the uh
and by the house of commons
as a whole i'll perhaps pick up
later that your description of the
tanker and the time taken to turn it
round when we've looked at the full
range of decision making over over the
following following years um if we then
just pick up your response to tony
newton at dhsc-000-3961
underscore 0-1-1 please lawrence
so this is a a a letter from you second
of november 1987.
and we can see bottom of the page
and uh that your name appears at the at
the bottom there and if we look at the
first main para second paragraph i have
to say that
although in terms of equity there might
seem to be some gains to be made from a
positive response it would seem to have
very real dangers
how could such a precedent be ring
fenced it could lead to an open-ended
commitment of huge dimensions
might it not give rise to court action
against the government because of the
implication of negligence
have the law officers given a view on
the possible consequences of a
sympathetic response i do not feel that
we can afford to offer such a response
until the pros and cons have been
thoroughly considered i therefore
suggest that you and john moore should
listen only at this stage and that the
most you should say is that you will
consider the points made by the society
with no implication that the government
will take action
and then you copy the letter to the
prime minister and the members of h.a
what did you mean or what what looking
at this now do you think you meant by
the
to in terms of equity and
some gains to be made i can tell you
exactly what i meant by it
that
consider the questions that were
unanswered and had to be answered you'll
note i didn't say that we shouldn't
offer it i said we shouldn't offer a
response until we thoroughly considered
the pros and cons of doing it
and those pros and cons were principally
how much money should it be
to whom should it go when should it go
in what form should it go what trap
doors would be open to present and
future claims on medical issues what
were the law
officers views on the implications of
offering no fault effectively no fault
compensation both now and in the future
now there was no uh suggestion
i think either by them or by me that
there wasn't going to be some
compensation but we had to be aware of
what we were doing if we were going to
get the compensation right and how we
dealt with it right
and frankly the department of health
should have examined that matter with
the chief secretary before they had
their meeting with the
hemophilia society but they hadn't done
so i think the meeting had come in a bit
of a rush for one reason or another and
they hadn't done so but before we could
decide what help should be given and how
the help should be given and to who the
help should be given and in what form we
had to answer those particular questions
and that was the purpose of my
cautionary letter to them saying listen
now
and then when you come back
we can discuss further
and and i understand the questions that
you're that that you've described and
that you're there you're posing also in
the letter but specifically the
reference to in terms of equity there
might seem to be some gains to be made
from a positive response
do you know what that meant
well i think we're talking about the
position of the hemophiliacs there so
the gains are not gains to the
government family i don't think the
government gained very much of the sort
of horror people were facing
i mean there's no amount of compensation
you can give that could actually
compensate for what had happened to them
what had happened to them was
incredibly
bad luck
uh awful
and and and it was not something that
anybody was unsympathetic to
i'm going to come back just so that
those listening notes to the to the use
of the word luck and fate which you use
in your statement and i want to explore
that with you at a at a little later
stage of your evidence yeah sure
um
just to carry through the
decision-making in relation to
um the requests that had come from tony
newton and john moore and we can see
then that the matter was considered by
the cabinet subcommittee on aids on the
10th of november 1987. could we have c a
b o
0 1
zero zero one six underscore zero one
one please
and
this is uh the set of minutes of the
meeting held on the 10th of november
1987 cabinet home and social affairs
committee subcommittee on aids and we
can see if we look at the those
attending it's chaired by
law white law and then we have a number
of secretaries of state in attendance if
we just go slightly down and we can see
john moore is there um
and you were there in your capacity as
chief secretary to the treasury we also
have a reference there to donald houston
the chief medical officer being in
attendance
if we could go please lawrence to page
six
um we can see the headings special
financial assistance for hemophiliacs
and then the minutes record the
subcommittee considered a memorandum by
the secretary of state on whether the
government should provide special
financial assistance for hemophiliacs
now i'm not going to take you to the
memorandum but for the sake of the
transcript so that others can look at it
if they wish to it's j e v a
five zeros two one
um but in fact the minutes largely set
out what it was that john moore was
saying
um
if we pick it up just in that paragraph
beginning the secretary of state for
social services said
it's about
about nine lines down um sir john
where uh it's recorded he had continued
the policy of his predecessor
in resisting special financial
assistance for hemophiliacs infected by
hiv
on the ground that there'd never been a
general state scheme to compensate those
who'd suffered adverse effects from
medical treatment
however he was now very clearly of the
view that the position was not
sustainable unless concessions were made
hemophilia society had recently launched
a campaign for government compensation
this had attracted a great deal of
support in parliament and elsewhere
and the society had been given advice by
council that it was most unlikely that
liability could be proved against the
government but they'd successfully got
across their contention that the moral
fault lay with the government for
failing to secure self-sufficiency in
blood products
whilst this was a tendentious argument
it was difficult to refute it
convincingly now just pausing the
message on before we look at the rest of
the document and the rest of the
discussion
you'll recall that the letters we looked
at from the hemophilia society
rather than simply calling for no fault
compensation had actually made out a
case
of fault
not necessarily legal liability but
fault on the part of
the government or the nhs
and
it for failing to secure
self-sufficiency and blood products and
then we see john moore then saying
describing that as a tendentious
argument but difficult to refute it
convincingly
it's not clear i think from the
contemporaneous documentation that
certainly i've seen
what was meant by that
or um
what investigation had been undertaken
as to
the alleged failure to secure
self-sufficiency
do you recall that being a subject of
concern or discussion
well at
35 years distance no
i don't um and nor would it be likely
that i would do
um i can think of various things he may
have meant but i don't know it wasn't my
letter and i don't know what he what he
did mean by that he may have meant while
it was tendentious legally for example
since he he makes the point also that
the advice they'd had was that
there was no legal liability doesn't
quite put it in that those terms
but that was certainly what uh
the government were being told as to the
strictly legal position
as opposed to the moral obligation that
i referred to earlier
in in very broad terms would you
accept this a moral obligation
might be said to arise in two ways that
there may be plenty more that i haven't
thought of but the two particular ways
one might be
the suffering is so great
that the government should take action
the other might be
there's a moral responsibility or a
moral case because although
for reasons relating to
difficulties in bringing legal claims in
the definition of duty of care there
might not be a legal claim
nonetheless there was fault
things were done wrong things were done
that should not have been done
do you
yes i i mean what was in the mind of the
i mean i can't remember this particular
meeting
but certainly what was in the mind of
the ministers who had discussed it with
me the health ministers
was the growing level of suffering that
that was what was moving their minds
their minds were not moving because they
had suddenly been told by the lawyers
golly that government are liable their
minds were moving because they thought
there was an obligation a moral
obligation because of the degree of
suffering
that was what was in their mind
um
if we then just continue we can see mr
moore continues he believed the
government should accept that
hemophiliacs suffered from a unique
combination of problems and that special
financial assistance should accordingly
be made available to them
it was most important that any scheme
go to the next page should be very
tightly drawn so that it could not be
used as a precedent for other claims
and then there is a um
further discussion in that regard which
i'm not going to read out but we can
pick up about 10 11 lines down we see
the proposal and he proposed that up to
10 million pounds should be made
available to the hemophilia society for
distribution
to cases of need
um
and then if we look at the bottom of the
page
thank you
so this is in relation to the issue of
funding
his centrally funded services program
for the current financial year had
already come under extraordinary
pressure the proposed financial
assistance could only be met out of his
so it could be met out of his budget
only by making cuts of around 10 in
non-demand-led services such reductions
in politically very sensitive areas
would attract great criticism and would
detract from the credit which the
government could otherwise expect to
obtain from his proposed scheme he
therefore sought the agreement of the
chief secretary treasury to the whole of
the proposed sun being met out of the
reserve
again
obviously these are john moore's words
rather than yours but the reference
there to the credit which the government
could otherwise expect to obtain
might be said to be looking at the
government's reputation
um
is is is was that is that your reading
of it is there another way in which one
could understand the references well i
don't know what john would have had in
mind um
uh but it certainly uh it certainly
could be read that way if one wish to
look at it in that particular way
i can only say that that wasn't
my impression from the discussions i had
had with john wall or with tony newton
so again is it possible that that that's
a little like the reference to to
political sustainability that's
potentially an argument being used to
win round others
well it's possible i mean it isn't my
letter
it isn't my phraseology so i i really
am not in the position to answer that i
can only answer for what happened
if we go over to the next page we can
see your contribution to the meeting
is in the second paragraph
the chief secretary treasury said that
he believed that there was a very strong
case for the government providing
financial assistance for hemophiliacs
with the hiv virus and it was important
that the scheme should be established
with the minimum delay however it was
vital that the proposed scheme should be
ring fenced as tightly as possible in
order to minimize the risk of
encouraging claims from other groups
which the government might find
difficult to resist
he wished to discuss with the social
services secretary where the part of the
cost could be went from the central
finance services program but if this did
not prove feasible he would be content
for the entire cost to be met from the
reserve
and i think as it happens the cost this
payment was met from the reserve to the
best of my recollection it was
the concern that the scheme should be
ring fenced as tightly as possible and
the term ring fencing will come up again
and again as we look at um
later decisions
why was that something seen it would
appear from this is so important by you
oh
simply because it's expenditure control
the more we spend money
the more we put up taxes or we borrow
that's the point i made earlier that is
always the case so that would be a
standard position with almost anything
that you you need
if you face something that was
unforeseen you will try and ring fence
it to people who really need the help
and not open a uh
a new door for
other people in other circumstances to
seek a similar scheme
and of course the government were very
worried about the fact that
they were breaking new ground it was the
first time
that any government had actually made
absolutely ex-grasha payments
for where there was no legal fault that
had not happened before so it was a new
situation
and nobody was quite sure how it would
work out so we needed to ring fence it
to avoid suddenly opening uh
opening the option for a whole range of
other claims to be made on wholly
unrelated issues
if we then just pick up the discussion
and if we go a little further down this
page please lawrence
in discussion the following main points
were made
um the first is is then about the
administration of the scheme i don't
need to ask you about that so john if we
go to the next page
just want to read out paragraphs b and c
and go back to this issue of government
credit so b says the hemophilia society
were present lobbying for the
introduction of a special form of
benefit which would cost the exchequer
around 60 million per annum the social
services secretary should arrange for
informal soundings to be taken of the
society to confirm so far as possible
that they would regard the proposed
grant as a reasonable sum the government
might not secure any credit at all if
the society were to dismiss the proposed
grant as wholly insufficient
c there was a strong case for the whole
of the proposed grant being met from the
contingency reserve the government would
lose a great deal of the credit they
might otherwise expect to secure if the
fund were to be established at the
visible expense of other sensitive parts
of the health service
so again we see this reference coming it
would appear from other members of the
committee
in the discussion to the government
getting credit
for making this this ex gracia payment
available
are you able to help us understand as a
member of the committee what what the
why we see that being featured as an
issue i don't remember any discussion
about that at this distance in time and
nor i think would anyone reasonably
expect me to do so
and i think there are various things
there is a
a whole range of different ways one
might have said that it wouldn't have
been my phraseology
because i don't think that was the
primary concern of ministers do you
recall whether there were
and i entirely understand the
difficulties of recording specific
meetings so long after the event
but do you recall more generally whether
there were
were particular members of the
government who were more resistant
to the idea of of breaking with this
long-established policy than others and
who who might need to be persuaded that
there was
an advantage to the government in
political or popularity terms well there
were fiscal hawks in the government
quite a few of them
um whether they were on that particular
committee or not i don't think in some
cases they were but it would probably
have gone to cabinet in some form
so that so there would have been there
would have been concern about that and
so there were people who would have been
quite hawkish about it
but that wouldn't have been a majority
but there would have been a minority
who would have been who would have
needed to be persuaded
i mean some of them might have had
within their own responsibilities
different groups
who could fasten on the fact that an ex
gracia payment had been made for
something and if excretia payment could
be made to the health department for
this particular cause why should not and
excretion payment be made in their
department for a group that we're giving
them a
reason to be concerned as well so
that is what i think is being
is being uh is being protected there
so that we don't need to come back to
this document again i'm just going to
pick up a couple of references to the
position of non-hemophiliacs who'd been
infected with hiv through blood
transfusions or transplant and so we can
see at d
um it says it was estimated that about
10 to 20 non-hemophiliacs have been
infected by hov as a result of blood
transfusions and other transplants
there was a strong case in fairness for
extending the scope of the proposed
scheme to cover these people and also
perhaps those who'd otherwise been
infected by hiv in the course of their
medical treatment
and that on the other hand such persons
did not suffer from the full range of
disadvantages of hemophilia with the hiv
virus
and there's a continuation of further
explanation in that regard and then if
we go over the page
we see um the lord president of the
council summing up the discussion
um i i'm not going to read it all aloud
but about 12 lines down there's a
sentence beginning the subcommittee
recognized that certain other groups had
a very strong claim to be to be included
in the scheme but they agreed that the
primary consideration should be that the
scheme should be tightly ring fenced the
social services secretary in
consultation but the chief secretary
treasury should consider whether if the
proposed scheme were to be extended to
other groups such as non-hemophiliacs it
could be ring fenced to them alone and
then there's a suggestion that further
that further work should be undertaken
very quickly
as i say i'm drawing attention to that
because we'll come on to the decision
making in relation to non-hemophiliacs
later
and then if we could go just a little
further down please lawrence this is
still in the lord president's summary
um
it's the last few lines it says on the
question of funding
the subcommittee had noted the strong
presentational advantages of shielding
the health service from offsetting
savings but the next step must be for
the social services secretary to consult
urgently with the chief secretary
treasury as he'd requested
now that reference to strong
presentational advantages is is that
about not making cuts from the health
budget
but using the contingency results
exactly
that's exactly what it means
and
so that that's the cabinet subcommittee
on aids 10th of november 1987. for the
sake of completeness
um i'll just read again into the um
transcript
the discussion was reported by the lord
president
to the prime minister on the 11th of
november dhsc zero zero zero two three
seven five underscore zero three two we
don't need to put that up lawrence and
then the cabinet
met
and i will just show this for
completeness cabo
000185
um
on the
12th of november
and we can pick it up at page five
bottom of the page so it's the last
paragraph we can zoom in on that
and so we can see mr moore refers to the
the
subcommittee um h.a's discussion earlier
in the week
um and then picking it up five lines
down he had now completed the
consultations that h.a had invited him
to carry out with the chief secretary
treasury preliminary discussions with
the hemophilia society of great britain
had also been carried out as h.a had
requested
the hemophilia society with us aware
that the government would assist them in
the administration of the financial
assistance being made available
and then there's reference to a meeting
later in the day of leading figures in
the society
uh picking it up a few lines further
down if as he expected the society's
support was forthcoming he proposed to
announce the financial assistance on the
following monday he would naturally make
clear in accordance with the advice the
solicitor general had given h.a that the
money was being made available ex gracia
and that the government expressly
disclaimed any liability for the
hemophilia patient's
infection
and it
whatever the nature of the discussions
that you and and john moore had had over
the preceding 48 hours or so
is this right the upshot was that this
payment of 10 million pounds would be
made entirely from the reserves and it
would be limited to
hemophiliacs so there was no extension
at that point in time to
non-hemophiliacs infected with hiv no we
knew the position of non-hemophilics
were coming to face us
that was self-evident the purpose of
ring fencing is is twofold
um it's ring fencing to make sure
that nobody else creeps into that and
starts taking some of the money away
from it so that to take a practical
example if you then moved on to other
people
who suffered from tissue transfer they
wouldn't be within that ring fencing
they would have to be dealt with
separately and outside the money put
aside for the hemophiliacs on that
occasion so the ring fencing isn't just
a budgetary measure to protect the
treasury it's to protect the money that
has been voted for a specific purpose to
be used only for that specific purpose
and then if we can just pick up your
statement
it's witn
5284001 please lawrence
um
um if we pick it up at the bottom of
page nine
we can see in paragraph 3.18 of your
statement
you referred to
the cabinet subcommittee meeting in the
cabinet meeting that we've looked at
at paragraph
3.19 and you've set out um your position
as we saw reflected in the uh
subcommittee minutes and then just over
the page
just wanted to ask you about what you
say in paragraph 320 there were risks
the hemophilia society were lobbying for
a new benefit cost 60 million a year
and others now in or in the future might
ask for similar support and once a
policy was broken it would be difficult
to hold the line against other claims
so risks took to whom risks to
government spending essentially risks to
government spending from
other completely unrelated claims once
we had broken the dam
of not paying out for no fault company
no legal fault compensation
once we moved to next gracious payment
we had opened up potentially a whole
range of other options where people may
come to the government or sue the
government or whatever in terms of
getting compensation for something
wholly unrelated to health
as well as conceivably related to other
aspects of health that's what it's about
it's the same argument about no legal
fault compensation
in terms of the sum that was paid the 10
million pounds
and
we
we saw um
the reference in tony newton's letter to
the kind of figures that they had in
mind and then by the time we get to the
cabinet subcommittee meeting
10 million is this 10 million pounds is
the sum
fixed on by john moore
and do you have any understanding
um from consideration of the documents
or
or recollection or your general
knowledge of how government worked as to
how that figure might have been arrived
at
um i wasn't involved
in arriving at that figure
but i think it would have been arrived
up on the basis of conversations between
treasury officials and the hemophilia
society and the assessment of treasury
officials of what the likely need was
going to be
and they wouldn't have undercut it
because they would then had to have gone
back again and asked them more money at
a later stage
and that's always a more difficult
proposition so they would have made what
they thought was a genuine assessment of
what the need looked like at that
particular time on that particular issue
and it would almost certainly i don't
know this for certain but it would
almost certainly
have related to discussions senior
officials like strawn heppell would have
had with the hemophilia society
and then discussed and costed within
the um
within the health department it would
not have been costed by the treasury it
would have been costed by the health
department so you would have expected
there to be but you would not yourself
necessarily have been party to
some kind of
um informed assessment to come up with
that figure i would have certainly think
i would have expected that i think it
would have been very important
of the health department to go to a
cabinet subcommittee or even the chief
secretary
without an assessment of how the money
was going to be used
it might be said
it might be submitted in due course to
the chair that this was a
a token sum and it really represented
the the least the government could get
away with paying at that time
would that be a fair or unfair comment
well
i don't think it would be a fair comment
i mean perspectives other people would
have a perspective 10 million doesn't
sound very much money today does it it
was a considerably more greater sum of
money in the late 1980s
and i don't think anyone thought that
was going to be the
end
if the awful problems
began to become more apparent and larger
um so i know the time and i'm going to
move next to so john's time as
chancellor so perhaps a good time for
the morning break just just one question
for you before we
break
uh
and it says
to to your knowledge does the inquiry
have any document which shows
any process which might be described as
informed assessment i hate it when you
ask me that sir um
i'm going to have to duck the question
and check um i don't think it does but i
i don't pretend to have looked at all
the documents that show how the 10
million pounds came up with not an
informed assessment certainly but that
might how 10 million was enlightened
upon i will need to check well the
informed assessment was uh what uh sir
john has just said he would have
expected it would have been improvement
of government not
to to have done that in some form or
other
uh and that's why i ask yes well we'll
check but i'm not aware of anything that
would be that would look like an
assessment of need yeah
um
let me say to you what i say to every
witness
at
the first break if not before
at this break and indeed at every break
please remember you are under oath you
must not
discuss the evidence you have given
or for that matter any evidence you
think you may yet be asked to give with
anyone
whoever that anyone happens to be
but you can talk about anything else you
like
uh we'll take a break now until 10 to 12
10 to 12.
is
yes
so before we move to 1989 i'm just
picking up upon the last matter i was
asking you about i think for the sake of
completeness
rather than necessarily because it gives
rise to a question and i wanted to just
put up on screen
tony newton's announcement of the
payment of the 10 million pounds
in parliament it's l d o w
zero zero zero zero two four one please
lawrence
we can see the date of the announcement
is the 16th of november 1987. and we can
see on the left-hand column it's being
made by uh tony newton um and if we just
go a little further down that column
please lawrence
we can see um penultimate paragraph on
the screen the grant of 10 million
pounds is being made from the reserves
but there's the announcement can we just
go back to the whole page please
you'll then see um sir john and um
chair bottom of the page robin cook
responds
and
if we go to the top of the next
column please
we can see the question being asked by
robin cook was will the minister explain
how he has costed the fund and come up
with 10 million pounds or was it a
convenient round figure
is he aware that per head it represents
just over 8 000 pounds for every person
infected and that that is less than half
the capital sum that is paid by his
department in cases of vaccine damage is
he satisfied that such a modest sum is
enough particularly when the most
pressing need for the families of the
victims is to keep a roof over their
heads by clearing a mortgage
um and then the next paragraph robin
cook asks if they'll be
if the minister will undertake to review
with the hemophilia society the size of
the fund and then mr newton's answer if
we just go a little further down the
column
um
he says in the second paragraph
on a number of occasions i've commented
on the difficulty of a compensation
scheme this is not a compensation scheme
that must be made clear it is a
recognition of a special and unique
combination of circumstances and i'm
glad to make that recognition
on the matter of the 10 million pounds
we arrived at a broad estimate of a sum
that we felt would give significant help
to the group affected
recognizing that to calculate in terms
of a specific sample individual would
not take account of the great
differences between the circumstances of
the individuals affected
that is one reason why we've not
attempted to have a regulated scheme for
example some may be young single men
others maybe older men with families and
so on on that basis we've arrived at
this summer and this flexibility of
scheme
and then he says in the next paragraph
it'll be up to the society because of
course the mcfarland trust
and ultimately to decide how to
administer the 10 million pounds um
there's then a debate that continues um
with some expressing the view that the
sun was less than adequate
um or rather scrooge-like and but that
that's the parliamentary debate in any
event um
for the sake of sake of completeness um
so john
if there's any comment you wish to make
on that please do i don't have a
specific question i just wanted to draw
attention to it to complete the issues
we were looking at before the break
no
i i don't honestly think at this
distance in time there's any
comment i can make that will add to what
you've just said
so if we move then two years forward in
time to the autumn of 1989 by which time
you had taken up the post of chancellor
of the exchequer
and if we can
start with hmtr
zeros one underscore zero zero five
um
now this is a minute from mr saunders in
the treasury dated the 13th of november
1989
and it is as i understand your statement
addressed to your principal private
secretary
and the heading is autumn's statement
hemophiliacs and aids
and it says in the first paragraph you
asked for a line to take
should the question be raised of
compensation for hemophiliacs you
contracted aids through treatment with
infected blood products
the following is based on briefing which
was supplied for prime minister's
questions yesterday
and then the line to take is um that
essentially it's a matter for the
secretary of state for health
um uh there's reference then to the 10
million pounds
department of health has always made
clear if representations were made that
further contributions were necessary it
would be prepared to consider them
and and then if we just go over the
page
and we can pick it up under the heading
not for use
so this i think is for your background
information rather than for public
dissemination uh paragraph five refers
to um consideration being given by mr
clark
who was said to be skeptical about the
need for any further payment mrs
bottomley is said to think that the
government must be seen
to be doing more
and now
this is
the genesis of what became a further
payment to the mcfarland trust
in
late 1989
as i understand it
sir john
you don't know if you
saw this at the time
but you think you would have
probably had some form of discussion
with the chief secretary who by then was
norman lamont about it is that right
well i don't know whether i would have
had a discussion as you put it with it
but i think it's likely that norman
would have told me about the letter
at our morning meeting um during the
period i was chancellor we would have
morning meetings
and all the treasury officials would be
there although they had quite
distinctive responsibilities they would
report on what was happening
so i would be surprised if norman hadn't
told me about it
but i have no recollection of it and
there was no action for me to take on it
and then um if we just follow
um
things through with a couple of
documents um again still from november
of 1989
c a b o
0 1
0 0 0 0 3 underscore 0 0 5 please
now this is an internal number 10
document from paul gray to the prime
minister 17th of november 1989
um and it refers to
um a minute having been provided by ken
clark proposing an early announcement of
a further 20 million pounds injection to
the mcfarland trust he said we know
warning this was coming there's no
evidence it's been cleared with the
treasury
um i don't think i need to read through
the rest of it
and bottom of the page however
last paragraph says earlier in the week
you did of course ask john major to have
a look at this and we had sought to
ensure that the treasury and dh looked
at this together and as i say it's not
clear that this has yet happened so the
best approach might be for you to have
an early chat with both ken clark and
john major before giving any reaction to
the 20 million pound proposal
and then
we can
see
at hmtr 601
underscore zero zero seven
um this is 19th of november 1989. this
records the prime minister
uh responding to to the secretary of
state for health's minute and saying she
wants to discuss it with the chancellor
of the exchequer and with the secretary
of state for health now as i understand
your statement in the documents it
doesn't appear as though a further
discussion directly involving you took
place but instead it was delegated to
the chief secretary to the treasury is
that right well i don't think it was
delegated in quite that fashion what
happened
i think was that the prime minister was
due to the hemophilia society
and she had another meeting with the
chief secretary
upon me
she had a meeting with the chief
secretary that was fixed and i think she
must have discussed it with the chief
secretary which was more appropriate
than talking to me about it since it was
by then his responsibility for
uh public expenditure
she might have minuted out she wanted to
talk to ken clark
as secretary of state and be as
chancellor but in fact within the
treasury it would have been norman
lamont who would really have dealt with
it so i suspect when he was with her
they had that discussion and my meeting
with her fell away and never took place
um
there are just a couple of further
documents i want to
ask you about
although i think there's no partic
direct evidence of of you contributing
to this discussion but you may be able
to assist us in understanding what's
being referred to
the first is hmtr
601 underscore zero zero nine
um now this is a
minute from mr saunders 20th of november
1989 and so again it's a treasury minute
to the chief secretary we can see it's
copied to you cc chancellor
and then we can see under the heading
hemophiliacs and age you're attending a
meeting about this with the prime
minister this afternoon and then we have
the reference to the
meeting the prime minister was having
with the hemophilia society
paragraph three
the treasury official says this you
should support mr clark's proposals
so long as he agrees to absorb the costs
as in paragraph five below and join with
him in resisting any pressure for more
generous treatment
and then further background is set out
about previous payments and what was now
being proposed
and then if we go over the page
under the heading discussion these
proposals are probably the minimum
required to meet public concern about
these cases so long as mr clark agrees
to absorb the costs within the survey
settlement for next year we can go along
with them but we need to be very careful
about repercussions in two directions
now just pausing there and before we
look at what mr saunders goes on to say
it might be said as though this minute
reads
as though it's the treasury official
effectively
telling the chief secretary what he
should or or shouldn't do you should
support mr clark's proposals was was
that was that normal no no no i mean
it's a treasury official advising
the chief secretary the chief secretary
may or may not take any notice of that
it's the treasury uh it's a treasury
official's duty to advise
he advises
that the chief secretary would make up
his own mind about whether he actually
took that advice
so there's no way you can dilute the
responsibility for the outcome to the
official
the decision would have been made by the
chief secretary and the chief secretary
is free to
challenge or reject the advice provided
absolutely
i mean the officials
in exceptional circumstances may suggest
a change of policy
but mostly they will reinforce
what the present position is and what
the dangers are of moving beyond it
but of course ministers have to live
with the decision that's taken
so the chief secretary would have been
entirely able to change it if he had
proposed to do so i don't know whether
he did but if he if he had proposed to
change it he would probably have called
a meeting with the official
and perhaps with
other senior officials
the
permanent secretary responsible for
public expenditure for example
and they might have discussed it and may
well have reached a different decision
and then i just wanted to ask you about
um something that said in the next um
paragraph
and it's really again trying to
understand
or get your assistance about the
the way in which decisions were taken
rather than this specific decision so in
paragraph seven and what said is there
is in logic no reason to compensate
hemophiliacs who contracted hiv from
infected blood products but not other
victims of the disease the department
and health authorities were almost
certainly not liable in the legal sense
and then it's this sir john and given
the state of knowledge at the time the
early eighties about the causes of a
method of transmission of aids there was
little reason to suspect that
hemophiliacs receiving factor eight were
at risk
now
certainly the evidence the inquiry has
heard based upon contemporaneous
material might put a different
complexion on that
and i'm not asking you to
express a view on the correctness or
otherwise of that statement but in terms
of process
this is someone an official within the
treasury
um setting out
in his advice to the chief secretary
a statement an assertion about the state
of knowledge
about the risks of aids in in the early
1980s
if a treasury official is going to
make that kind of statement or provide
that kind of advice
what would you expect it to have some
proper evidential basis for that and and
how would you expect
the department to go about
exploring whether that statement was
correct or not
well i don't know what evidence the
official who wrote that would have had
but of course aids was becoming a
significant problem at the time norman
fowler was chairing committees related
to it
those committees would have met
advice would have been given to those
committees that advice would have been
enshrined in the um
in in the
reports of what that committee discussed
and decided and the official may well
have been drawing on what was said to
the aids committee i don't know
but i suspect
that is probably the official wouldn't
have made it up
he would it would either have been a
matter that was common knowledge as it
were or it would more likely have been a
matter that was picked up from other
government documentation that had been
copied to him
but which he not necessarily was part of
would you be right to say that that a
treasury official
and this is a matter of generality i'm
not asking you to comment on what mr
saunders himself was saying at this
point of time but a treasury official
should not make that kind of statement
would you accept unless there's a
some form of evidential basis for it
well i don't about should not i mean in
my experience they didn't
make that sort of statement without some
sort of knowledge because it would have
been a mistake to do so
so
i do not know where that knowledge came
from and i wasn't involved in it but i
suspect as i said that it would have
come from some other document within
government
probably the minutes of uh
something related to the aids committee
and then just to complete again the
picture in relation to
this decision-making in november of 1989
um if we go to hmtr 601 underscore zero
one two
and so this is uh 20th of november 1989.
it's from number 10 paul gray at number
10 uh to
an official within the department of
health and we can see it refers in the
first paragraph to a meeting having
taken place involving the prime minister
the secretary of state for health the
chief secretary to the treasury um and
also the attorney general to
consider this announcement of a further
20 million pounds allocation to the
mcfarland trust
um i just want to ask you about two
passages within this letter and again
it's really for your general
observations to john rather than
any direct involvement if we could just
go down a little further please lawrence
third paragraph
so
the letter records this summing up this
part of the discussion the prime
minister said it was agreed that the
issue of whether or not to proceed with
a further allocation to the mcfarland
trust need not be affected by the
position reached in the legal
proceedings
the issue therefore fell to be settled
on political grounds
and
knowing as you must have done the prime
minister mrs thatcher fairly well
by that point in time um
do you have any
uh insight into what that reference
might be to political grounds
it's clumsily phrased uh that is
certainly true
um i think what they're seeking to say
here and then the last sentence is
clumsy and
capable of misrepresentation
what they're saying there is that
we need not do things on the basis that
we were likely to lose in court
we had to reach a political decision
on what to do now that political
decision would be based on many things
it would be placed as you will
undoubtedly put to me on pressure
perhaps in the house of commons or from
the hemophilia society
but it would also uh have been based
upon whether it was the right thing to
do or the wrong thing to do in terms of
helping people who were in a desperate
situation
now
you could have expressed it in that
fashion and enlarged the summing up
but the summing up is inevitably not
word perfect it may not even be an
absolutely accurate version
in that it was abbreviated of what was
actually said by the prime minister i
have no idea but it would certainly have
embraced what the political situation
was and that would involve
the concern
the moral concern
the need for people to get help
and the political pressure all of those
things would have been a focus
which was the dominant focus in the
prime minister's mind i have no means of
knowing but it would have involved all
those i'm sure
and then just to pick up on them on the
issue of the moral focus if we can if we
go over the page
said
second paragraph in discussion the
following points were raised one
in presenting such a package it would be
desirable as well as to avoid as well as
avoiding any acceptance of legal
liability to avoid conceding any moral
obligation rather the emphasis should be
on the special circumstances of this
particular case although distinguishing
the position of the hemophiliacs from
other difficult cases like vaccine
damage was not easy
um so
there
you you previously spoken about the the
moral case or the moral obligation this
appears to be
prime minister secretary of state chief
secretary to the treasury
not obviously you part of that meeting
saying that there shouldn't be a
concession of a moral obligation
um
again really drawing on your knowledge
of the government at that time can you
help us understand why that might be the
case
well i guess i can
almost certainly
if the government had started talking
rather than acting on the question of a
moral obligation if they had started
talking bits it's the old problem of
opening the gate to all sorts of other
things that i'm sure would have been
what is in their mind
you can think everyone in this room can
think of a dozen things where you could
argue someone has a moral obligation to
do something
and
the government has to guard against that
if it is to keep control of events and
keep control of the sum total of its
expenditure so it is the same point that
we came up to up against earlier
it is uh
it is trying to ensure that whilst there
must be extra help it's presented purely
as an ex gracia payment
without indicating
the underlying
elements that created the need for that
excretion payment
that i am sure would i do not know i
didn't write it but that i'm sure is
what would have been in their mind
if we then move now
nearly a year forward to october 1990 so
to the last um a few weeks of of your
time as chancellor of the exchequer
um and
as you'll know um sir john
litigation referred to commonly as the
hiv hemophilia litigation
was ongoing
um and that came to your attention in
october of 1990
and if we can just work through a
handful of documents not all of them
would have been seen by you and but if
we start with
hmtr
zeros
underscore042
now this is
a minute of the 2nd of october it's from
mr edwards so 2nd of october 1990 to the
chief secretary to the treasury
and
if you look at the names there is this
copied to
your office it doesn't seem to be no
um and then we can see in any event that
there's reference to there's been a
discussion with mr clark
um and the issue that's now come to the
fore is whether the government should
negotiate an out of court settlement or
let the court case proceed that's what
set out in paragraph two
and then
and if we look down towards the bottom
of the page we can see some advantages
and disadvantages set out of those two
courses so advantage of negotiation
would be the government hope to settle
the matter quickly avoid a long
drawn-out court case attracting much of
program over an extended period
top of the next page
disadvantages of negotiation would be
likelihood of a more expensive outcome
high probability that the existence of
the negotiation and any offers made
would leak and cause the government
further embarrassment in a program
see the improbability of settling out of
court for a sum as low as 24 to 30
million
and then d
if as is all too likely the existence of
the negotiation leaked but no deal was
struck the government's condition would
be far worse than if no negotiation had
been entered at all a failed negotiation
would give the critics a field day and
the trial would proceed on the basis the
government was prepared to offer 30
million
and then paragraph 6
is
the policy of letting the case proceed
without any attempt at negotiation and
then we see again the advantages and
disadvantages set out
a strong probability the government
would win
b the likelihood of setting damage in
expensive precedence would be much less
c
the risk of embarrassing leaks from
behind the scenes negotiations would be
avoided so those are the advantages and
then top of the next page
disadvantages would be the likelihood of
continuing criticisms over an extended
period
and b the slight risk of losing the case
badly and then paragraph based on the
above analysis the strategy of assuring
negotiation and letting the court case
proceed
looks to be clearly preferable certainly
from the treasury point of view and
probably from the point of view of the
government as a whole
now
looking at those pros and cons and again
i'm really asking for your
your observation as an informed insider
rather than someone who was directly
participating in the the decision making
at this point in time sir john but that
discussion of pros and cons
is very much looking at
government spending cost to the
government reputation criticisms of the
government
there's no
what might be said there's no reflection
there of the position of
the the hemophiliacs
the advantage of alleviating suffering
etc
is there anything you can assist us in
understanding why the treasury might be
presenting it from that point of view or
looking at it from that point of view
well the treasury would have been
looking at it purely from
the point
if it had come from other departments if
you come from the department of health
you may have seen that but the treasury
would be
speaking to its own responsibilities and
its own responsibilities
are to control expenditure within reason
and sometimes it's not possible to
control expenditure and it wasn't here
and it soon became apparent that it
wasn't here but the treasury would have
put forward its argument and it would
have no doubt entered into debate with
whomsoever they were discussing it with
uh or whichever committee it may have
gone to and a conclusion would have been
reached
but the treasury wouldn't have put
forward a case and then undermined the
expenditure case by adding other issues
as well
and that would have been true since the
dawn of time the treasures as far as i'm
aware
so the treasury's primary concerns
because it is the treasury would be
fiscal and
political
yes i think that's a slightly harsh way
of putting it if i may say so i can see
why you do that
but um
i think it might be fair to put it the
treasury has to advance the case that
the treasury is there to advance and the
treasury is there to protect and advance
the quantum public expenditure and the
direction of public expenditure
as you will have seen what has happened
in the past the treasury appeared to be
resistant when it went into discussion
with the chief secretary and the
department of health the treasury wasn't
really resistance at all when you got
down to discussing the actual impact
that it was intended the sums made
available before
if we just follow this through and so
that was second of october if we just
pick it up at hmtr six zeros one
underscore zero four three
we get to the 5th of october
um
and
again it's mr edwards to the chief
secretary if we just look at paragraph
four please so if we go just further
down the page
it says you may wish to check before
writing or talking that the chancellor
so that was user john is of a similar
persuasion hence the square bracketed
final paragraph of the draft letter if
we go over the page
this is the draft that had been prepared
by treasury officials for the chief
secretary to send to kenneth clark as
secretary of state for health and we can
just see the second paragraph explains
um
the line to take the treasury is
suggesting is that any attempt to
negotiate an out-of-court settlement
would be a bad mistake we have to let
the hemophiliacs representatives bring
the court case if their intent is they
appear to be on doing so
and then there's a discussion again of
the pro pros and cons set out in the
letter i'm not going to go through that
again it reflects the document we just
looked at if we go to the bottom of the
next page
we can see there's a very
last paragraph on the page
there's a bit in square brackets john
major has authorized me to say that he
shares my views on this now
that i think it was anticipating and
that the minute would suggest that the
chief secretary would
discuss with you and
and try and ascertain what your views
were
i i don't think the documents
tell us if that happened or not
and it's probably a stretch to ask you
to remember sir john but do you know
whether that's a conversation that took
place or not
well if uh
if norman lamont said that he had
discussed it with me then he would have
discussed it with me
do i remember it at this distance in
time it might have been a very brief
discussion at the morning meeting
we had in mind to do this
and i dare say there was more to it than
that
we have it in mind to do this are you
content and i would have said if that's
what you think is the right thing to do
norman go ahead
but was i involved in a structured
discussion about this
i don't recall one
and i don't know of anything in the
official documentation that suggests
that i was
but of course at this distance in time
who could be absolutely certain
but i don't think so i just want to
briefly bring up two documents just to
show where the position had got to by
the middle of october so the first is
hmtr
zeros one underscore zero four six
this is mr edwards 15th of october
actually that square bracketed bit at
the end may have been i mean you've seen
the letter with the square brackets in
it that may have been before he
discussed it with me and it's in square
brackets because he was intending to do
so that's my reading suggestions he may
well have done that so maybe he didn't
discuss it with me but i simply don't
know no there is attached to the
document that we're just about to look
at there is a later version of the of
the draft letter which doesn't include
any reference to you so i don't think it
um
it's by no means clear whether there was
a discussion with you
so this is 15th of october
and
there's a reference to there going to be
debates in parliament in the house of
commons and the house of lords i just
want to pick up paragraph 2
department of health officials assure me
the government line on both occasions
will remain exactly as it has been
hitherto
there will be no suggestion that the
government might be willing to negotiate
an out-of-court settlement so
this is really just to just
show the chronology of events to john
in the weeks before you became prime
minister so that that's the position set
out in this minute and then
if we look at
dhsc
zero zero four six nine
six underscore 0-3-5 please
we can see this is the 16th of october
1990
and if we go just a little further down
the page please lawrence
right hand column we have mr wallace
um asks a question does the prime
minister agree that the honorable and
decent way forward in the tragic case of
the 1 200 hemophiliacs suffering from
the aids viruses to offer far more
generous compensation than has been the
case up to now rather than continuing to
fund ever increasing fees for lawyers to
argue the toss over the matter and then
we have the prime minister's answer the
government have already made available
some 34 million pounds to the
hemophiliacs who are suffering from this
very grievous happening as an excretion
payment without prejudice to their
taking legal action in the courts
obviously we wish to know the legal
position before any further payment is
considered
um so
i don't have a question for you sir john
that's to show
where things had got to by the middle of
october at
1990
and now you became prime minister 28th
of november 1919
but before we look at then how this
issue came to your attention as prime
minister
can you just help us a little bit
understanding more
the organization of number 10 and and
how it might be that
decisions or documents might come to you
as prime minister
um and and what might not
be put before you was was there any
particular rule of thumb
well it wasn't really a rule of thumb i
mean it was a pretty rigid uh
set of circumstances
things would typically come to the prime
minister if they were likely to be
controversial
if there was something upon which the
prime minister need to needed to rule
if there was something that the prime
minister had previously spoken about any
of those would mean
that uh documentation was copied to the
prime minister
it might be copied to the prime minister
for all sorts of other reasons as well
it might be copied to the prime minister
if the secretary of state thought
hang on at some stage this is going to
come back and bite the government in
some way on any issue
so therefore we better make sure that
number 10 knows about it now
and so they write a memo and they copy
it to uh
to number 10.
these submissions would come into number
10 they'd come into the private office
they would be filtered by the various
secret economic secretary foreign
affairs secretary and so forth
and then presented almost certainly to
the prime minister's principal private
secretary who would decide which of
those matters actually had to be seen by
the prime minister
straight away
and which had to be held because they
had been sent in case something would
happen in future so that number 10 had
been informed about it and could carry
it forward
now i don't know what percentage
of the things that are referred to that
are copied to number 10 are actually
seen by the prime minister
but my guess is that it would be a
pretty small percentage
that were actually seen simply because
of the sheer volume of paper i don't
wish to set out all the other things
that take the prime minister's time
suffice to say there is a great deal
and the paperwork is
absolutely extraordinary
so the job of the private office would
be to protect the prime minister from
having to read things that were not
immediately relevant
very important or whatever it may be
they would be very selective in what
they showed him
but
they would keep the correspondence to
hand in case something else occurred
that meant the prime minister should go
back and read
that earlier submission to number 10.
now around a week after you and became
prime minister
um mr waldergrave who was secretary of
state for health wrote to you
and and if we can just follow through
the correspondence over um
the the days that that
then followed
we start with hmtr
six zeros two underscore zero one six
please lines
um so this is addressed to you
if we go to the the second page um
first of all
we can see it's dated the 5th of
december 1990 and it's ww so william
waldergrave
um if we go back to the proceeding page
we can see uh mr waldegrave said this
further to your exchange with terence
higgins at yesterday's questions i'm
writing to let you know the current
position on the hiv litigation involving
hemophiliacs
and then he sets out a number of points
by way of background the third paragraph
refers to the two payments um previously
made
fourth paragraph explains however around
770 infected hemophiliacs and 190 of
their partners and close relatives are
suing the government and the health
authorities for damages alleging
negligence
the main court hearing has been set for
march 1991 as it's expected to last for
six months the trial judge took the
exceptional step of suggesting that both
sides should consider a compromise
settlement in its formal rejection the
department said that the moral and
compassionate arguments had already been
recognized by the government and drew
attention to the dangers of creating an
expectation that all those injured as an
unintended effect of nhs treatment would
receive compensation without having to
prove negligence
however the coordinating committee for
the plaintiff solicitors have now put
forward a proposal which would in effect
involve a total cost to the government
of some 50 million pounds
this is very much lower than their
earlier proposal of nearly 100 million
pounds and may i am advised represent
the fact that the doves amongst their
lawyers are temporarily in the ascendant
over the hawks we therefore have a
choice before us which i'm about to
discuss with the chief secretary and
about which i will then want to manage
you legal costs of going on maybe 20
million pounds or so political costs are
high on the other hand precedents are
dangerous
the purpose of this note is not to ask
for a decision since i've not yet had my
meeting with hmt
and the costs
and benefits of either course are
therefore not yet agreed but to warn you
that the last occasion when a decision
other than to fight it out could be
taken is going to occur in the next few
days
meanwhile obviously we must play um a
dead bat
and so
uh um obviously i can ask
lord waldergrave as he now is about that
when he gives evidence
at next week um but that's
the minute he sent it to you on the 5th
of december not asking for any
particular action or decision on your
part yet
yet
is it likely given it's directly from a
minister to you that you would have seen
that
i think it certainly would have seen it
and then on an issue like this
and from the secretary of state i'm sure
i would have seen it
and then we can then just pick it up on
the 7th of december
when um
mr wildegrave wrote to you again hmtr
602 underscore 019
so this is a covering minute which gives
the date of the 7th of december um
and we can see from the covering minute
it says as agreed i enclose a copy of
the minute which has gone to
the prime minister um this evening
and then if we go over the page
so this is again from william
waldergrave to
and he refers to the earlier minute of
the 5th of december 2. i was able to go
through the issues in detail with the
chief secretary yesterday evening we
examined in particular the proposal put
forward by the plaintiffs council
three the conclusion was that provided
that the plaintiffs would commit
themselves to accept their council's
proposal
we should be prepared to accept it on
our best estimates the cost of such a
supplement would be higher than the most
favorable outcome from fighting and
winning the case but much lower than the
cost of fighting and losing the case
badly our council have put the risks of
this as between one and three and one in
six
it would also be likely in practice to
be cheaper than fighting and losing a
significant minority of the cases or
fighting initially and settling out of
court later
um
mr woodgrove then records a conversation
he'd had with that the leading council
for um
the government
um
who'd had a conversation with the
plaintiff's council
paragraph five says that that council
reported back that rupert jackson so
that's the plaintiff's lead council
believes the proposed settlement would
stick and will advise the plaintiff's
steering committee to accept it
um in rupert jackson's view the longer
the affair continues the more difficult
it will be for him to get agreement from
his clients
if we go to the next page
and
we then see um
the reasons mr waldergrave sets out for
um not
passing by the opportunity to settle
this so he says this the chief secretary
and i believe that we should not pass by
a possible opportunity to settle this
very difficult issue
we are coming under increasing pressure
to settle not least from our own back
benches
so that's the first point pressure from
backbenchers
settlement now would enable us to avoid
the long drawn out court cases beginning
next march in which public sympathy
would be with the hemophiliacs
so that's again
we've got the back bench view now the
public view being set out
then the third reason given it would
also strengthen our position in dealing
with rosie bond's private members bill
on no fault compensation
uh the amounts payable per person
um as shown on page one of council's
proposal attached would not be publicly
regarded as overly generous though the
plaintiffs have of course received
twenty thousand pounds each or more from
the government already
we think it would be better to settle on
the figures proposed by the hemophiliacs
council if his clients support him than
to bargain publicly for lower figures
which would carry the risk of sparking a
public auction in which the government
would receive little credit and could
end up by paying more
and then paragraph seven
that said we should clearly need to
handle our response with the utmost care
and then there are a number of points
set out again i'll ask mr woodgrove
about this in more detail in due course
but he says we mustn't go beyond the 47
to 51 million pound figure which looks
generous by international standards
recipients would have to undertake to
drop existing cases for swear bringing
any future cases
all the plaintiffs would need to accept
the settlement
um and then there's a reference to a
subcategory of medical negligence cases
and then bottom of the page plaintiff's
counsel would need to advise his clients
that the offer provided a reasonable
basis for discontinuing the court action
um
if we go over the page
and paragraph eight refers to social
security disregard again i don't need to
ask you about that sir john paragraph
nine um refers to where the money will
will come from in terms of settling the
negligence cases and then paragraph 10
sets out mr wardrobe's proposal to you i
would propose without directly accepting
the hemophiliacs council's proposal to
instruct andrew collins to ask their
council to confirm with his clients that
they would settle on the basis he has
proposed we must ensure that the
settlement figure which has been
proposed remains the hemophiliac's
council's figure and does not become the
government's office still less the
government's opening offer and then
paragraph 11 asks for your authority
to proceed accordingly
we must expect that news of the
negotiation will leak when council
consults his clients he would however be
consulting his clients about a proposal
which he himself has made
and i would propose for the time being
to make no public comment
top of the next page
if we're asked point blank when the
negotiations are taking place we would
propose to say that the plaintiff's
representatives have been in touch with
us but that we have no further comment
to make um
now
what's your understanding of why this
was coming to you for your authority to
proceed
was it something that required prime
ministerial approval
well i think it was uh
probable
that they thought this was an issue of
such size that he'd ought to have prime
ministerial
approval and because of course it was
breaking
with all precedent
breaking with all precedent on no fault
compensation so therefore the department
wished to know
that the prime minister was content to
breach
the previous method of doing business
and agree to a payment of this size
uh without um
without any subsequent difficulties
coming back
the variety of things about it
very unusual for the judge to suggest a
compromised settlement that the judge
did suggest a compromise settlement
and the coordinating council for the
plaintiff solicitors
themselves did exactly the same
now there were a vast range of things to
consider here
it would have been
absurdly foolish i think not to have
taken the opportunity of settling
an issue
that had
caused a great deal of anguish for the
victims
but also
was
dragging on for so long that one needed
a definitive settlement
and it seemed to me that it was entirely
right and if that could be an agreed
settlement rather than an imposed
settlement
it was far more likely to be acceptable
to people
whatever an imposed settlement would
have been
there would have been
disputes as to its credibility to its
stick ability
and to much else besides
so it seemed i i had no doubt william
aldegrave was a very powerful advocate
for settling he wished to settle
he thought it was the right thing to do
um
and the chief secretary agreed
that it was the right thing to do i
assume this all came out of reserve i
can't recall now but i'm sure it would
have done
and
i thought it was the right thing to do
for
the reasons i've just set out
and the moral obligation reason i
referred to before which so upsets
people because governments don't
actually write it in there
in their in their minutes
but i did make two stipulations to that
and they were the stipulations that that
had been suggested and it was important
to make it clear that this was not
imposed on a take it and leave it basis
by a government who said you're going to
lose the court case if you don't take
this you'll get nothing that was not
remotely the state of mind nor was it
what happened
so i did make the two stipulations which
are probably i'm going to take you today
so that we can just look look at exactly
what you said so
if we go next to c-a-b-o
zero zero zero zero zero
four four underscore zero zero seven
now before we look at the handwriting
sir john um this is a a minute to you
um from uh dominic morris within number
10 at 7th of december
1990. we can see the first paragraph
refers to the health secretary's
attached minute so that's the document
we've just looked at
and then um we see mr morris setting out
what essentially a summary
the position in relation to to the cost
if we go further down
and that's yes if we just pick it up
halfway down that long paragraph that's
at the top of the screen
um
the basis is that the hemophiliac
steering committee would accept it as
full and final settlement of their case
that committee represents most but not
all of the victims there's no guarantee
that some of the plaintiffs represented
by the committee and some of those whom
it does not represent would not hold out
for a higher figure but the health
secretary's view is that faced with the
prospect of continuing legislation i
think that probably should be litigation
and a settlement which most had accepted
the remainder would settle
and then the three risks in the approach
first is um there might be pressure for
a higher figure
the second is the precedent for future
cases
um and then over the page
and the third is the treatment of
social security payments
um and then it records both barry and i
think that these are significant risks
but clearly the health secretary
chief secretary tony newton and council
think they're outweighed by the
advantages of settlement on the basis
proposed and then you're given two
options content to accept the health
secretary's proposals or do you want a
meeting early next week to discuss it
further
that handwriting is that yours
so you were content to accept the health
services secretary's proposals and you
didn't want further just a further
meeting if we go back to the first page
then if you can help us with the
handwriting that's mine
um yes
yes yes it's if you could help us
read exactly what it says
um i know by hand i know what a and b
say because it's it's then typed up in a
minute from your office but it's the
first bit yes yes i could easily live
with this but a it must be clear it's
the plaintiff council's proposals and
his figures and b
he must get agreement to accept before
we announce figures
i can i can take you to the tight
written copy which tells us what the
rest of that says thank you very much
hmtr i'm grateful for that six zeros two
underscore 0-2-0
and say 10th of december
and this is dominic morrison number 10
um writing to the department of health
and so this is recording your your
decision that you've written on on the
memo we just looked at uh the prime
minister was grateful for your secretary
of state's further minute of 7th of
december he agrees that it is right to
settle this as soon as possible for many
reasons he agrees that the health
secretary should proceed as he proposes
but and then we have the stipulations
as you've described them it must be
clear that it is plaintiff's council's
proposals and his figures
plaintiff's council must get agreement
from his clients to accept before the
government could announce figures
until then it is very much plaintiff's
council's initiative so those i think
were the missing words
on the
copy that we had
now
why was it um
important
in your mind to be clear that it was the
plaintiff's council's proposals and
figures
because i didn't want people to think it
was an arbitrary proposal
enforced upon them by the government
i wanted it to be understood that it was
an agreed proposal
and indeed that the agreement had
actually emanated from those
representing
the victims of the hemophilia disaster
and then the second stipulation must get
agreement from his clients to accept
before the government could announce
figures until then it's very much
plaintiff's council's initiative
what was your thinking there well if his
uh
uh if
if his clients um to borrow your phrase
had said no
then he would no doubt have wished to
put an alternative to us
so
i thought it was in everyone's interest
to make sure that it was an agreed
settlement
so that nobody could be aggrieved later
as a result of the settlement that was
actually made i much prefer agreement to
dispute and here we had the chance of
agreement and it seemed prudent to make
sure that those who were affected by the
agreement
actually accepted it
from their own representatives as being
fair
rather than being seen to grudgingly
accept it at the hands of the government
so at this point in time
were you anticipating that
the matter would be considered by the
plaintiffs themselves who
who i think as far as we know were
unaware of the proposal that had been
put forward
and which the government was was minded
to agree to
um that that that they should be
informed in agreement should be sought
before there was a
an announcement by government yes that
was my intention
and when you said there before the
government could announce figures do you
know what you had in mind there was that
the overall settlement figure or i was
thinking both of the overall settlement
figure
and the to the plaintiff's
representative would tell them
how it would affect them in the
individual categories
um
that that was a matter for him not for
us
um now if i can just then pick up what
what happened in terms of the
announcements because there's some um
some um
questions about that
hmtr
six zeros two underscore zero two one
please
um so this is from
jeremy hayward
uh and we can see it's from the chief
secretary to the treasury's uh uh
department 11th of december 1990 i think
with respect it was to the chancellor
oh i'm sorry yeah
uh
so mr hayward was private secretary to
the chancellor at that point
you're right it's addressed to the
chancellor sorry i was just describing
who it was from the chief secretary of
the chancellor yes
um and then um we can see mr hayward
sets out this as i told you
mr waldergrave wants to announce this
afternoon
that the government has agreed in
principle to accept the proposals put
forward by the plaintiff's council for
an out-of-court settlement mr
waldergrave's office have supplied their
proposed text to us copied to you
crucially mr waldergrave apparently
wishes to make this announcement whether
or not the steering committee of lawyers
representing the hemophiliacs has
signaled its agreement to council's
proposals the steering committee is
meeting council at 1 30 pm today this is
of course completely at odds with what
the chief secretary agreed with mr
woodgrave last week and inconsistent too
with the prime minister's view dominic
morris's minute of yesterday and that's
the document we just looked at
having discussed this with the chief
secretary i've suggested to number 10
and to the department of health and
alternative form of words against the
contingency that the steering committee
does not agree to the plaintiff's
council's proposal this afternoon
and then we can see the alternative form
of words is
um
uh could be so much rather more
non-committal
i understand council of the hemophiliacs
has been discussing with this client as
a possible settlement i welcome that the
government will of course look at any
proposals the plaintiffs may wish to put
to us i cannot comment further at this
stage
if we go over the page
records number 10 thought this was
exactly right the department of health
did not mr walter grey phoned the chief
secretary on the car phone to make clear
his view that a public announcement that
the government was prepared to deal
would in fact help to secure the
steering committee's agreement the chief
secretary expressed the country view and
stressed that it was not in mr
waldegrave's own interest to do anything
that would increase the risk of the
government being driven to accept a more
generous settlement the treasury had
already been more than generous
the chief secretary believes that we
should now leave this to the prime
minister's political judgment i am
fairly confident that dominic morris
will suggest that the form of words
above is more appropriate unless of
course the steering committee does agree
today with council's proposed settlement
and now again i can ask mr waldegrave
about his own thinking but if we just go
back to the first page
the handwriting at the top of the page
it's it's not your writing this isn't a
document you were seeing but it says the
pm
has now gone along with the waldergrave
proposal and has announced that we are
settling
um
we'll look in a moment at what you said
and then what orally and then what mr
waldegrave said in in writing but can
you assist us in understanding why there
was what might be said to be a change of
position about how the government would
deal publicly with this issue
well i'm not sure how much of that would
really have come to me in detail i had
obviously said that i agreed with
william waldergrave how much of the
undergrowth had actually come to me and
how much it was a dispute between the
two departments
i really don't know at this distance in
time
so i think my recollection is that the
plaintiff's council did agree and so we
went ahead i made a generalist statement
an answer to a question in the house
and william made a detail william
waldergrave made a detailed statement
in the house
i think possibly either that day or the
following day i forget which
well if we just look at those two
statements um
uh
to
complete the factual picture
so the first your own statement is at
dhsc zero zero zero
three six five four underscore zero zero
three
um so this is the 11th of december it's
um prime minister's question time it
would appear
um and
uh
there's a question from john marshall
we'll see mr marshall's role when we
look at the
issues of
hepatitis c in particular but your
answer is um i can now tell the house
that the government has been examining
this matter and have been able to agree
in principle to proposals being put
forward by the plaintiff's lawyers
provided the proposals are formally
approved by individual plaintiffs and in
the case of minors by the courts they
should provide a basis for bringing the
matter to an agreement successfully and
soon my right honourable friend the
secretary of state for health will
inform the house of the details i'm sure
all members of all parties will welcome
this development as i do
um
if we just look then at mr waldergrove's
written answer
eight dhsc-002086 six underscore zero
three four please
and
uh
so i think we need to go over the page
yes we go over the page
top of the next page
mr waldergrave says this this is the
11th of december they said this is a
written answer
the steering committee of solicitors
representing the hiv hemophiliac
plaintiffs and their council have put
forward to the department of health
proposals for the settlement of this
litigation which they regard as a fair
and reasonable resolution of the
plaintiff's claims
uh governments have carefully considered
these proposals agree they'll provide a
fair and proper way of ending this
litigation and of making financial
provision for all affected team of fully
acts of their dependents
and then there's a reference to a belief
that the case is legally strong etc
um the government of therefore agreed in
principle to meet the steering
committee's proposals and then we see
the figures being
as in
overall figures being given in outline
the compromise would result in the
government providing to the mcfarland
trust in addition to the 34 million
pounds of wedding paid a further sum of
about 42 million pounds for distribution
to all hiv hemophiliacs and their
families according to their respective
circumstances furthermore the
government's agreed that payments from
the mcfarland trust will not affect
entitlement to social security and other
statutory benefits the plaintiff's
reasonable legal costs would also be
paid by the government
because the proposed settlement will
require the formal approval of all
individual plaintiffs and in the case of
minors of the court it would be
inappropriate at this time to publish
further details
until all plaintiffs in the court have
had an opportunity to consider the full
terms of the settlement and to approve
them
now
it might be said
that what's been done here by mr
waldergrave announcing the overall
figure
is is at odds with your stipulation
that we looked at of your second
stipulation
that we looked at a few minutes ago
is that how you understand the position
and if so are you able to under explain
to us how that came about
i don't know how it came about at this
distance in time
i suspect i suspect the concern was that
the agreement would leak
because the agreement
the agreement was uh
reached between was known to a number of
people it was known to the treasury who
i don't think would have leaked it was
known to the health department who
probably wouldn't but it was also known
to an awful lot of people
at the hemophilia society and elsewhere
and people who had been approached so
there was a head there's a real chance
that it was leaked it would have leaked
and i suspect that this distance in time
it was the danger of a leak
that would probably have persuaded
ministers and i assume i was asked about
it
that we should proceed straight away
before it leaked
and began to become very messy
and did the tabling by mr waldergrave of
the written ministerial statement
bounce you into making an announcement
against your better judgment no no
i'm sure i'm sure i wouldn't have done
i mean at the at the end we work very
closely on these things and and now he
he wouldn't have done that
um
leaving aside the question of whether
what was done was
um a change from what you
contemplated in your stipulations or not
why was it thought appropriate to make
any announcement in parliament
before the plaintiffs leave aside the
steering committee the lawyers but the
plaintiffs themselves
had been consulted let alone
a moment ago
i assumed the answer this system's in
time unless there was something
that i can't remember i don't know
but i'm assuming looking at it that the
reason would be that we had been
concerned we would have been concerned
about a leak
and it may well have been a partial leak
it may well have been an inaccurate leak
uh the danger that
is created time and again by leaks
that are only partial or inaccurate
of what is proposed by the government
it's a constant concern
so i suspect this distance in time i
don't know but i suspect that would have
been a material factor
and then just one final document on on
this issue of of how the announcement
was made
hmtr
602 underscore 023
and this is a minute
from strawn heckle in the department of
health to mr edwards in the treasury
um
it's 12th of december 1990 if we just
look at the text before we look at the
handwriting
uh says i attach a copy of the press
release which the plaintiff steering
committee put out yesterday afternoon
um you'll see from this well the
steering committee comment that the
figures do not represent proper
compensation and moral terms they do
make it plain that these are figures
that they would be prepared to recommend
to their clients
um
i don't think i need to read the rest of
it if we can just go look at the
handwriting
i don't think if we just look at those
who are copied first of all
is there anyone here um who represents
number 10
as far as you can recall
he um alex allen probably doubts or he
may have been at the treasury then
he may have been at the treasury still
but he did go to number 10. i don't
think there's any evidence to suggest
that this document with these
annotations was seen by by you
in any event we have in what i think is
the handwriting of mr edwards of h and
treasury these words
vexing as dh's handling of this was
it turned out as well as or better than
we might have expected
x one is encouraging that's just a
reference to um an annotation later in
the letter we don't need to worry about
that
i will however make clear again to dh
that this was no way to do business
uh in the meantime i've asked them to
ensure that their press office gets
across the point that the government has
already provided 34 million pounds um
do you have any insight into what what's
being referred to there is the
department's vexing handling or of this
being no way to do business
well almost certainly to change the
announcement procedure i would think it
just occurs to me looking at those dates
12th of december 1990
that would have been right in the run-up
i'd only been prime minister for
14 days
i don't know it's quite possible i was
in america
um
meeting president bush and discussing
when the
gulf war would start
now i haven't been able to check my
diary but certainly
my diary was overwhelmed
with pre-gulf war preparations as you
might uh imagine
visiting the gulf
to talk about a whole series of things
including the funding of the war looking
at the stationing of the soldiers
the enormous problems we had we were
very concerned in the month leading up
to the gulf war and at the beginning of
it
that the
iraqis republican guard had biological
and chemical weapons
and we were very very concerned that
they would use those chemical weapons in
the gulf war which
started at the beginning of
the 12th of january
so
if there were things i didn't see that
may well have been the reason i could
have been overseas either in
uh either in the middle east or in
america or i just could have been so
buried under the legislation that things
things were discussed between the
treasury and the department of health
without necessarily involving they have
only just noticed the dates
yeah
that might have been it we know you were
in parliament on the 11th of december
because that's your announcement but
your announcement but in terms of the
12th of december um i don't i just don't
know but i i would have known
what would have been consuming my mind
at that time
would have been the onset of war because
we feared
very many uh casualties and the
department of health was very much
involved at the time
in what to do to prepare in case our
servicemen were met with a chemical or
biological
threat
when the fighting actually started
and then before we rise for lunch and
just to to complete the the
documentation in relation to
um
the the settlement of the litigation
and
shortly before
you became prime minister
mrs thatcher wrote a letter to
alf morris 2nd of november 1990
hsoc0012332
um
uh
uh so it's it's in response to a letter
from mr morris um enclosing a letter
from
uh the general secretary of the
hemophilia society
and if we just
skate down the page first of all
we can see the second paragraph she says
she that she is appalled by the tragedy
as moved as everyone else by the plight
of those infected
next paragraph says never disputed our
moral responsibility to pay attention to
the needs of the victims in their
families
and then
the last
paragraph on that page is despite our
promise to keep under review the 34
million already made available
many hemophiliacs have decided to pursue
legal proceedings alleging negligence
against
government licensing authorities et
cetera the case is before the courts
over the page
mrs thatcher sets out um
the
the successive government policy in
relation to no fault compensation i
don't propose to read out that long
passage and then in the last sentence
the last paragraph she says i'm sorry
this is a disappointing reply but the
government is showing its great concern
for hemophiliacs with hiv by the
excretion payments it's making
the question of compensation has to
remain a matter for the courts to decide
um
so that's mrs thatcher's position
not long before you take over as a prime
minister and as we've seen one of your
first steps as prime minister was to
agree to what mr waldergrave was putting
forward to you as a as a compromise of
the hiv litigation
to what extent was
the change in government and and
mrs thatcher being replaced by you
a factor
in the settlement of the case
it's difficult to say
um
i cannot answer for mrs thatcher's views
nor would i
seek to do so
um to the best of my knowledge
we never discussed them one meeting that
we were going to had as we discussed
earlier was replaced with a meeting with
the chief secretary because it involved
expenditure
but i suspect
that if mrs thatcher despite this letter
if mrs thatcher had been presented with
an acceptable
agreed solution
i suspect that she would have taken it i
can't be certain of that but i suspect
she would
certainly to me i was in no doubt that
an agreed settlement was the best option
because even if it had been
even if the government had gone to court
and won the case
it would not in my mind
have ended the legitimate claim for help
from the hemophiliacs who'd been damaged
by infected blood
so we needed a settlement
however the settlement came about we
needed one
and an agreed settlement between those
acting for hemophiliac victims and
government was self-evidently the best
way to proceed
and then can i just finally ask you
about one comment you make
in your autobiography on this issue
so if we go back to rlit
0001628
please
let me go to page 7 of the
document
bottom of the page
you say this another priority so this is
the last paragraph of john less specific
perhaps was tolerance a conservative
value which some tourists overlooked and
which i aim to restore to the fold two
swift acts set the course i decided to
unfreeze child benefit payments this was
achieved at my request in norman first
budget and to compensate hemophiliacs
he'd been infected with the hiv virus as
a result of contaminated blood
transfusions
both of these decisions achieved a
certain notoriety and were seen by some
as signs that i was breaking with what
had gone before this was a
characteristically false history the
broad tradition of our party was
tolerant
and then you say this if a certain
shrill and sensorious tone had set in
it was that tone which broke faith with
our past
my predecessor was not personally
unsympathetic but some less tolerant
than she saw thatcherism as a vehicle
for intolerance and sometimes prejudice
and now i'm not going to ask you about
what you say is that the role of
tolerance within the conservative party
sir john um it's the reference to
in the context of discussing this very
issue in your autobiography the
compensation for hemophiliacs infected
with hiv
to a shrill and sensorious tone
um and
some who saw thatcherism as a vehicle
for intolerance and sometimes prejudice
who or what did you have in mind there
the
every political party
is a coalition
it doesn't any political party or any
size is a coalition
and that is true of the conservative
party as well
and there are some people in the
conservative party who take
what you might kindly call a very
hawkish view of social issues
the everyone understand on their own two
feet argument
rather than an argument that understands
that there is a responsibility for those
who can to help those who cannot
and i was referring to the minority
who took the stand on your own two feet
argument to extremes
self-evidently in our society there are
a lot of people at any time not least
now
who need help from those who are in a
position to give it
and the mainstream of the party i joined
was always in favor of doing that i was
very much in favor of doing that it
wasn't a universal view with inside the
conservative party
then as now and it was to that that i
was referring
and the shrill and censorious tone came
from that group and not from mrs
thatcher i didn't particularly have mrs
thatcher in mind when i said that
because as i said i think if she had
been presented with an agreed settlement
i cannot be certain but i think she
would probably
have been advised to accept it and would
have accepted the advice
people who don't know mrs thatcher
assume the legend of mrs thatcher is the
real mrs thatcher
but underneath the the legend of the uh
uh
unyielding iron lady
was someone who often did yield
and often did a look at things
on a human basis to a much greater
extent than she has given credit for
may not universally have been true but
in my experience it often was
and i saw her of course
as
a social security minister
when she gave me my first job in
government
she put me in social security and said
that is where i started
learn social security and you'll
understand something most people in
parliament never will
and then in my later jobs
as chief secretary i had a lot of
contact with her and self-evidently as
chancellor
so
i perhaps saw more of her than most
and i saw her in the private unguarded
moments
as well as in the official
the official uh
prime ministerial role where a policy
had been made and she stuck to it
rigidly but it is it is simply
some of the myths about mrs thatcher and
her hard prejudices are simply not true
they are not the mrs thatcher that i
knew
she did have some very hawkish views but
they were not universal
and they were not views against hardship
in the community in the way it is often
presented
but in any event as i understand your
earlier evidence on this particular
issue compensation for hemophiliacs you
didn't have any particular discussions
with mrs that's no i had no discussions
with them at all as far as i recall
so i know the time and i'm going to have
any formal discussions certainly thank
you
um i'm going to move to a different
topic after lunch
right well we'll take a a break now for
lunch
and
come back at five past two by past two
just before miss richards starts uh
again with her questions can i just say
something
i was spoken to by someone who was
listening or trying to uh this morning
and they they said to me that they had
been distracted by the noise of people
talking a bit too loudly around them
uh either see some people are nodding um
please by all means you will feel the
need i'm quite sure at times to say
something to your neighbor but if you
can do it in such a way that it doesn't
disturb other people's concentration i
think they would be grateful
miss richards
sergeant i'm going to turn now to the
question of um
the extension of financial assistance to
non-hemophiliacs infected with hiv
yep and we can pick it up
in april 1991
at dhsc zero zero zero two eight seven
two underscore zero zero one
yep dhsc
zero zero zero two eight seven two
underscore zero one one i'm sorry i
think i said zero my apologies lauren's
yep zero one one
so this is a briefing for number 10 24th
of april 1991
um and we can see it's headed
hiv-infected blood transfusion
recipients
as distinct from hemophiliacs and then
we can see there are five short
paragraphs to the briefing the first is
in general the government doesn't accept
the case for no fault compensation uh
however it recognized that special
circumstances applied to hemophiliacs
with hiv
the next paragraph refers to what was
said to be the double disadvantages for
hemophiliacs because of pre-existing
hemophilia the third paragraph deals
with the hereditary nature of hemophilia
and the implications of that
and then the fourth and fifth say this a
similar combination of factors would not
generally apply to blood transfusion
cases in principle blood transfusion
cases are no different from other people
who suffered from medical accidents or
the unintended side effects of treatment
so that that was the government line if
i can put it that way as at
1991
and
i'm just going to show you one other
document and then ask you about that
line
if we go to dhsc zero zero zero two nine
one two underscore zero zero nine
this is now the end of 1991 second
december 1991 and it's a letter from you
to john marshall mp and we can see that
over the page
uh we can see um the john marshall is at
the bottom of the page
he'd written to you
um raising this issue with you as he did
i think on a number of occasions over
the years
and so your response we go back to the
previous page
um if we look up in the second and third
paragraphs
you say we made clear when we made the
settlement in the case of hemophiliacs
that they were a very special case the
government has acted accordingly of
every sympathy with the plight of those
non-hemophiliacs who've been infected
with hiv as a result of blood
transfusions but as you know the house
has very recently decided on a free vote
that it did not support the principle of
no fault compensation for medical
accidents
every case of a patient damaged by
medical treatment represents a human
tragedy but the cogent arguments which
led the house to reject the principle of
no fault compensation apply i believe
also in this case
so
you were as i read this letter to john
is this right effectively holding the
government line
maintaining the government line
the government line was almost certainly
under discussion by then but yes that
was holding the government line uh john
marshall i should say was
a regular correspondent his uh
constituent was the chairman of the
hegophilia
association and he was a very strong
supporter of
any help he could possibly get and he
pressed continually for it
and he would often approach me in the
lobbies and talk about it privately he
was a he was
as good a friend to the haemophiliacs
who were suffering
as anyone in the house um
and he was very close to them so when
one heard from him
one did stick to the government line
until one of the certain the government
line had changed
do you
have any recollection of what your own
view was about that government line but
by this time
uh we're talking of april well we the
first document we looked at was april
this is now december 1991
um
and the line is being maintained at this
point in time it changes in early 92 as
we'll see
that um the
hemophiliacs
infected with hiv had been a special
case
and that those infected through blood
transfusion should not receive any
financial support
do you recall anything of your own
thinking about the tenant how terrible
that line was
these um
approaches came to me very irregularly
indeed after 92 there were none at all
for three years
so i wasn't sitting on top of the
problem all the time which was lodged
firmly elsewhere
i saw it when it was brought to my
attention and i responded to what was
immediately in front of me and it may be
one of 30 or 40 things in a day
so if you ask me precisely what my
thinking was at that time i can't
honestly tell you what it was at that
time
we moved to a situation where i thought
that the
the line that we taken was and
not only unsustainable but unfair and we
moved on but what i actually thought at
the time i signed that letter
i really can't honestly tell you
whether there was internal discussions
inside number 10
because although
one discusses this with other
departments as well
there's also a policy unit inside number
10
and there are the very senior officials
who are private secretaries inside
number 10
and often one would be discussing that
with them and indeed
it was one of them within the next two
months
who began pressing very hard the fact
that the government line was he didn't
put it quite this way but both unfair
and unsustainable
and i think that's probably mr chapman
and we'll look at that in mind yes and
just just before we do if we could look
at hmtr
six zeros three underscore zero five
three
now this is 29th of january 1992
and it's mr chapman forwarding to the
department of health
that a copy of a letter from
neil kinnick who was then the leader of
the opposition
and then if we look at the second
paragraph it says i should be grateful
for briefing for the prime minister on
the same subject by close of business
3rd of february in preparation for a
meeting which he is having with john
marshall
mp and others
so
it would appear that things have moved
forward a little at least from your
letter to john marshall because you have
agreed to see him on this subject is
that right
and if we go over the page
this is mr kinnick as he then was letter
to you
dear prime minister uh
you'll know the most recent exchanges in
the house on the subject of compensation
for non-hemophiliacs
who've accidentally been infected with
hiv during blood transfusions or tissue
transplants
like many other members of parliament
and of the general public i had expected
that the government would by now have
provided compensation for these tragic
victims of accident i was surprised and
dismayed therefore to see that virginia
bottomley has said that the government
would not make provision for the
non-hemophiliacs on the same basis as
the hiv-infected hemophiliacs even
though it's obvious that both groups
were victims of similar and serious
treatment events
making provision for the
non-hemophiliacs would be elementary
justice
far from involving untold expenditure as
mrs bottomley claimed it would involve a
relatively modest sum and be completely
justifiable as a way of at least easing
the economic disadvantage suffered by
the people afflicted with hiv i must
appeal to you to accept that on moral
and logical grounds there should be
compensation for these unfortunate
people and ask you to take immediate
action to see that it is paid i think
top of the page there's some handwriting
um which i don't think we can
clearly discern what that is but is it
was that your handwriting
my handwriting is pretty bad but not as
bad as that
um
in any event
looking at it now do you think that mr
kinnick's
intervention might have been played a
part in
in the government reflecting on the
position found it difficult to disagree
with what neil kinder wrote
and we were moving in that direction
uh and then if we just picked so i would
certainly have taken into account what
he said
and then if we just pick it up with mr
chapman's
note to you then
uh c-a-b-o-5044
underscore zero one one
and so this is dated the 3rd of february
1992 the dates on the second page
from william chapman 2u and it's
obviously a briefing in anticipation of
the meeting
um
uh mr marshall's coming to see you
tomorrow to discuss the question of
people infected with hiv through blood
transfusion following the award to
hemophiliacs who were infected by hiv
through blood transfusions controversy
has now switched to non-hemophilia
similarly affected
i attach a brief from the department of
health of which you need only read the
first three pages plus the page on ring
fencing just pausing there i'm not going
to take you to the the department of
health briefs to john but i'm just going
to read the the references into the
transcript so others can follow it if
they want to at a later stage
cabo
5044 underscore zero one two
cabo five zero four four underscore zero
one four and cabo five zero four four
underscore zero one five other documents
i think to which mr chapman were
referring
he then recalls that mr waldergrave's
still not given up hope of extending
help but is meeting treasury resistance
surely the government will sooner or
later have to give way on this one and
the sooner it does so the more credit it
can rescue
treasury argue that it's difficult to
ring fence the case of people infected
with hiv so that special groups who've
suffered at the hands of the nhs will
not have a precedent to claim
compensation however this seems to
ignore a couple of points
the other groups which are thought to be
in the wings are all suffering from
non-fatal diseases hiv by contrast is
probably the inevitable first step to
aids and is almost certainly a death
warrant
in a sense the past has already been
sold by the grunting of eta hemophiliacs
the government argues that they are a
special case because their lifelong
condition has been exacerbated by hiv
unlike non-hemophiliacs have been
healthy up until the time of their need
for a blood transfusion this cannot be
true because some of the latter must
include for example people suffering
from leukemia the government's position
seems increasingly untenable
you may like to use the occasion of the
meeting with mr marshall to seek a
report on the position citing the above
arguments
you may not recall what your response
was at the time but looking at it now
and is there anything in what mr chapman
says that you disagree with absolutely
nothing
and we saw it there again the reference
to credit
if we just go back to the first page
it's the fourth paragraph where he poses
the rhetorical question surely the
government will sooner or later have to
give way on this one and the sooner it
does so the more credit it can rescue
that again does seem to suggest
this is a remark of an official not a
politician not a minister
so i'm afraid i can't answer for what uh
uh what william had in mind when he said
it
but
clearly
it is better to do something that is
right before you're forced into a
position where you have no choice but to
do it and he was probably making that
point so to reinforce his
recommendations
um now you you had a meeting on the
fourth of february with mr marshall and
others um well we can look at it briefly
and for the sake of completeness it's ca
b o
five zeros four four underscore zero two
three
um so this is again from mr chapman
it's addressed to the department of
health
and it refers to
um the meeting that took place the day
before
with a group of mps who are there named
and who include mr marshall
it records a number of points made by
the delegation i'm not going to go
through the detail of those bottom of
the page
this records your response the prime
minister expressed his personal sympathy
for those affected he had to be
concerned however that the case could
set a precedent and help to lead to no
fault compensation given the state of
the art of blood screening at the time
it was difficult to say conclusively
that the nhs was at fault it would be
helpful if a clear robust position on
ring fencing could be established if
compensation were agreed recipients
would need to undertake as the
hemophiliacs had done that they would
not pursue extra compensation through
the courts
and then over the page
the prime minister agreed to consider
the matter further and to discuss it
with your secretary of state and the
chief secretary
so
um
is it right to understand this letter as
essentially saying
that you would you were not opposed to
the provision of financial assistance
provided it didn't set a precedent for
other cases in the old terminology it
was not as good is as good as a wink
to those members of parliament that we
were actively considering the matter and
that's what it was yes
and indeed
i think pretty soon
because the discussions that obviously
include william included william
waldergrave privately
he very soon came back with some more
proposals
yes as i said earlier about william he
was
a foremost advocate of help
throughout his period
and
if we go to hmtr
603 underscore 063
and this is william waldergrave 2u 7th
of february 1992.
the first paragraph refers to the
meeting that you'd held with
a
handful of mps
and the the last sentence of that first
paragraph says you will have experienced
for yourself the strength of feeling
that the issue is causing across all
parties
two i'd put proposals to the chief
secretary for resolving this issue on
the same lines as we did for
hemophiliacs
but for reasons which i well understand
he did not feel able to agree three
however given the mounting parliamentary
and public concern i believe we should
reconsider my proposals
and then there are three elements set
out i'm
not going to ask you about that
paragraph five we must recognize the
risk of weakening our general opposition
to no fault compensation the chief
secretary is rightly concerned about
this but we shall have to make plain
we're responding as with the
hemophiliacs to very special
circumstances that our general policy
remains firm
and then top of the next page just deals
with
where
in in terms of the source of money where
the money
might come from
now
i'm not going to trouble you sir john
but there's an exchange of further
correspondence some of which i think
might have been copper to number 10 some
not but involving mr waldergrave and mr
meller mr has already given evidence
about the issue mr waldegrave will be
giving evidence next week but there are
issues about ensuring that there's a
ring fence there and where the money
will come from and so on
resulting in an announcement in
parliament on
the 17th of february 1992 are
thereabouts that the um
financial support along these lines
will be made available
and
looking at it now
perhaps
conscious of i think it's in this part
of your statement you use the analogy of
the tanker the government as a tanker
taking a long time to turn around
and
did the government
try to resist this additional provision
for non-hemophiliacs for too long did it
take too long to get to the position in
february 92
of making some financial support
available for the first time for them
it had been possible but it wasn't very
convincing to draw a distinction between
hemophiliacs and non-hemophiliacs with
hiv
and as the discussion developed it
became pretty clear
that the policy as it existed would have
to change and would have to include this
a new group
that said
at the risk of
repeating what i've said before
the concern about no fault compensation
and the direction in which that could go
was a genuine worry with the treasury
at a time when
other budgets were being chopped uh
because of the inflationary spiral that
we were seeing in the early 90s
and
more expenditure would mean more
reductions
elsewhere
so perhaps it was longer than it would
normally have taken
had we not had exactly the difficult
economic background that we did at that
precise moment
but the
direction of argument
was moving inexorably
to the position upon which we finally
landed i don't think i would argue with
the argument that it could have been
done sooner
i can only say in retrospect
you could often see things a little more
clearly than you can
when you have a dozen other things in
front of you at the same time and
perhaps that was true of everyone
involved
can i turn then to the issue of
financial support for those infected
with hepatitis c
and
if we start
with dhsc zero zero zero four four nine
eight underscore one four three
and so
this is a
number 10 letter um
to
the department of health
november 1995.
and it says here under the heading
hemophilia and hepatitis c you'll recall
we discussed the possibility of the
prime minister meeting a delegation of
conservative mps led by john marshall to
discuss the case for compensation for
hemophiliacs who've contracted the
hepatitis c virus
the prime minister remains unconvinced
that it would be sensible for him to
meet the delegation however in light of
the recent concern expressed by a large
number of mps the prime minister would
like to consider the case for a brief
meeting more carefully
to assist him i should be grateful for a
short briefing on the issue to include a
summary of the line he might take in
such a meeting
now we'll look at a handful of documents
in a moment to john about about decision
making but
this might suggest that essentially
um
you number 10 was really being led by
the department of health or the
department of health was leading on this
issue
um
and setting the policy
is that right well they certainly were
of course they were it was a health
issue
so it would
inevitably be led by the secretary of
state for health
um
number 10 would lead perhaps on macro
issues but by and large there are
20 or so departments of state and they
would all have their own
responsibilities and they would lead on
it so naturally
the department of health would have been
in regular contact with in a way that
number 10 couldn't possibly have been
now this uh this correspondence is three
years on
from the last set of correspondence we
take within those three years between
1992 and 1995
no document relating to
the blood tragedy collectively
came to number 10 that i'm aware of
certainly none has been unearthed it
would have been dealt with by the health
department so self-evidently they were
leading as they should have because it
was their responsibility to lead they
were certainly leading
on the policy
and it wasn't their intention to lead
number 10 in a particular direction
every department of state tries to lead
every every prime minister in a
direction they personally think is
correct
that is their job
would it have been open to you
nonetheless as prime minister to say i'm
not sure i agree with this line this
policy
and to push back and to take a different
view of course
and
if we just look at yours if i could just
add to that of course it would it would
have been within my authority to to do
that
but if you have one of your senior
ministers pushing for a policy
it is pretty unwise not to have it
properly examined before you say yes or
before you say no
because you would have an outline of the
problem
but probably only an outline the
secretary of state whether his education
or health or defense
would know
far more about it than anyone in number
10 possibly could
so just to brush it aside because you
had a whim that it was wrong or to
accept it because you had a whim it was
right
would be pretty flippant decision making
you you actually need information and
you need facts
and you need costs in order to make a
proper decision
because your decisions aren't just made
on your behalf
they are and i hope this doesn't sound
pompous they are meant to be made on
behalf of what is right for the country
and what is right for individual groups
within the country so you must examine
what is going on on important issues as
this certainly was
before you actually make a decision
now what you said in your statement i
don't think i need to put it on screen
but it's paragraph 3.58 of your
statement is
um that that the department had felt the
line could be held to those who
contracted hiv through transfusions and
there was an innate resistance to going
further
and what was the cause of that innate
resistance
was it purely fiscal
i think in terms of hepatitis c
there were two reasons
um inevitably in everything any
government does there is a fiscal view
either it is
easily granted or it isn't
and in the financial position of the
1990s very little was easily granted so
of course there would have been a fiscal
element
there is also the comparison
between the position of hemophiliacs
themselves and hemophiliacs with hiv and
those with hepatitis c
which as the hemophilia society
themselves conceded in letters was a far
lesser risk
and as the medical advice we
received and they received i confirmed
that was the case so it would have
probably been and i'm
assuming what was in the department of
health's mind because they didn't set it
out in a note to me i'm assuming
it was a combination of those two things
that they were referring to in terms of
the innate resistance
they may also have been referring to a
third thing
and that was the innate resistance in
parliament
as a whole
um
to the vote against no fault
compensation in a private member's bill
that had been
taken some time before
i just want to look at it could have
been any one or all of those three
things
i'm just going to look at a handful of
documents in relation to hepatitis c
with you
it's an issue we're going to be picking
up with with law torum john horum on
wednesday in more detail
but if we just look first of all it's
cabo
5044 underscore zero four zero
um this is um a a communication from
five mps
um 30th of september 1995.
so it includes john marshall
the first paragraph refers sorry if we
can go to the thank you the first
paragraph refers to
what's said to be one of your earliest
decisions as prime minister to
compensate hemophiliac suffering from
hiv
and then it refers to the widening of
that to those who had been infected
through transfusion
the second paragraph is this there's now
an allied but similar problem there are
some 3 000 hemophiliacs who've been
infected by the hepatitis c virus as a
result of being treated with infected
blood products
of these some 600 will die
and over 50 have already died this has
resulted in the anomaly that those
hemophiliacs who have died through hiv
have been compensated whilst those who
have died through hcv have received
nothing
this is we believe unacceptable
now
that that communication would
have informed you that although
hepatitis c was different in some
respects from hiv
it was nonetheless a decision that
could lead to and had led to
a significant number of deaths
do you
do you have any recollection whether
that that resonated with number 10 with
you with your colleagues with the
department
well i
i have no recollection of it but of
course i have read the papers again
and looked at it so i'm i'm familiar
with the position
that was taken then
and a position that i must have taken
then though if you ask me but i actually
remember it the answer is that i don't
i think we were infected
affected
by the usual arguments that i have
repeated again and again about no fault
compensation
but beyond that we were
influenced undoubtedly by medical
opinion
advising us that hepatitis
c sufferers were in a very different
position
overall
uh from those who previously have been
granted compensation
and and i think the information we were
given as to the number of deaths was
every death is tragic but it was
wholly different
from the information from the
delegation of senior conservative mps
that you referred to a moment ago and
and very very different
there were other things factors i think
at the time
um
the british government wasn't the only
government
in uh in refusing compensation to
hepatitis c victims presumably for the
the same reasons
um almost every other country and maybe
all of them i can't be certain of that
it did not offer compensation to
patients contracting hepatitis c
and i dare say that would have been a
significant factor
and of course the information we had
from
the hemophilia society itself graham
barker's letter to arthur freya as a
case in point if you have that to hand
illustrates the distinction between the
two so it would be a combination of
those things
i don't know in retrospect whether that
was the right decision it's impossible
to know
you take the decisions with
the focus of immediate events you look
at them later a good deal
in retrospect
and you wonder on a number of fronts
was i wrong perhaps by being too under
generous was i wrong with being too over
generous
i've never been entirely certain with
hepatitis c whether we took the right
decision then but that was the one that
we took
if i can just suffice to say if i
remember rightly
um
10 years later
i think hepatitis c patients were
granted
some compensation i don't know how 2003.
by the then government of sorry six
years later eight years later
um
and i think that was probably right
and then i just want to pick up um
a couple of documents with you i think
in fairness particularly given the an
observation you've just made
i should show you first of all cabo
5044 underscore 041
and this is from
mark adams
so an official within number 10 i think
to to you
um it refers to
uh
mr marshall and others pressing for the
government to compensate those infected
with hepatitis c department's currently
drawn a firm line between the two
viruses whereas hiv almost invariably
inevitably leads to death hepatitis c
need not although some estimate that as
many as 20 of those contracting the
hepatitis c virus will die
um and then there's a recommendation
that you give the group a hearing and
the question is content for us to fix a
meeting um
if we can then just look at a follow-up
minute from mr adams to you c a b o
five zeros four four underscore zero
four four
and so this is the 16th of november 1995
and the first paragraph tells us that um
refers to the earlier discussions and
the second paragraph refers to an early
day motion having been tabled
and mr adams says this in the
circumstances i now think it is the
least you could do to meet the
delegation
and then is this your handwriting sir
john
it is so to to say what
a brief on the issue and
can you help with the next two words
just
it's our line a brief on the issue and
our line before we decide please
so i was asking for a brief
and then i
think that um the brief that you
received um
doing the best i can may be there cabo
five zeros four four underscore zero
four two
and before we look at this i'm just
going to read another document so this
is a
a short document and then there's a
background document the reference for
which but we don't need to put it on
screen is cabo
5044 underscore 043
and
this
says um in terms of the line to take
greater sympathy for those inadvertently
infected but no fault no negligence on
the part of the nhs has been proved
secretary of state for health has
reiterated the policy of his
predecessors that he does not believe no
fault compensation as a sensible use of
nhs resources agree with that judgment
the principle involved is not one which
will colonel should be lightly breached
then there's the reference to the
precedent already established by hiv and
what it said there is that was in light
of their very special circumstances
those affected were subject to
significant social problems and were all
expected to die within a short space of
time
and then there's this question and this
is really what i want to ask you about
so john how could this have been
prevented and the answer is this
patients concerned received best
treatment available in the light of
medical knowledge at the time
as soon as reliable tests became
available 1991
all blood donations tested to prevent
hepatitis c infection
so it would appear from this that you're
being told by the department of health
two things there patients received best
treatment available
and that as soon as a reliable test was
available blood was tested for hepatitis
c
and
if
if you're being assured of those factors
prime minister
would you
expect that someone within the
department of health would have
undertaken some investigation inquiry
analysis
to check that those assertions are
are correct that there's some proper
foundation for them
well i think that's a reasonable
assumption don't you
if it turns out that there was not a
good factual basis for either of those
assertions the assertion about best
treatment available
the assertion about the um
testing as soon as a reliable test
became available would that concern you
now
well i don't know whether that has been
the case
it's a hypothetical because i don't know
but it's hypothetical
um i mean i can see
one thing someone's got a reliable test
something else happens five years later
when you you you find you haven't
well that would be concerning
because the department of health
were themselves wrong perhaps had been
misled by medical advice
and
the advice to me had been wrong and
perhaps the decision taken was wrong
but it's a hypothetical
i'm certainly not aware that that was
the case
let me put it a different way it's still
a hypothetical question because
obviously the briefing you received was
the briefing you received
if you had received a briefing which
said
um
how under the heading how could this
have been prevented there are some
question marks about whether patients
receive the best treatment available
there are question marks about whether
um they were provided with proper
information about risks and there is a
question mark as to whether there was a
delay
in introducing screening
so in other words if you've been told
that there potentially were steps that
could have been taken
that might have prevented or reduced
this
do you think your response in terms of
the provision of financial assistance i
can tell you exactly what my response
would have been my response would have
been let me have the information that
you've just hinted at
give me the details of what wasn't done
and what the effects were of not having
it done
because without that i wouldn't have
been in a position to make a judgment
based on facts
but i didn't ask those questions because
i wasn't advised that
if we then just look at cabo 500 cabo
607
zero zero four
and this is a follow-up minute from mark
adams to you first of december 1995
again it refers to the approach by mr
martial and others and your request for
more information
and if we look at the second paragraph
he refers to the briefing which i think
is the document and that we just looked
at
um
and then
bottom of the page he says the only
purpose of meeting the delegation would
be to be seen to be listening to a
campaign which is gathering ground
across parliament including many in your
own party and then there's references to
mps who'd signed the early daymotion and
hemophilia societal publication
and top of the next page
you say although there's some merit and
are meeting to be seen to be listening i
understand why you feel this may create
more difficulties than it solves
alternatively you might prefer the
delegation to me to minister in the
department of health
can we just go back to the first page
because it's actually the handwriting i
wanted to ask you about then
um is this your handwriting again it is
yes and it says please return i'd like
to discuss with the chief whip
and what what is it you think would have
you'd have wanted to talk to the chief
whip about this
i would have wanted to discuss the whole
issue with the chief whip
the prime minister sometimes wants a
dispassionate piece of advice
not from the secretary of state who has
as it were a direct interest in the
outcome but somebody quite dispassionate
and it may have been that
quite whether it was that or not at this
distance in time how can i know um
and
there's no notes taken of meetings with
chief whip so there's there's nothing to
indicate what it might have been
so that is my guess
um now um
you turned down
a meeting with uh mr marshall and and
that's cabo 607 underscore zero zero one
um sorry next page policy science
so 26th of january 1996.
um uh you refer to mr marshall's letter
of the 30th of september you apologize
for the long delay and you say but as
you know from your discussions with
alastair goodlads i've been considering
the issue carefully alistair goodluck
was who the chief whip
um and then you explain why you
understand why mr marshall's pressing
the case
um
you refer to the very special nature of
hiv in terms of the the government's
line and then the next paragraph you say
that john horum has been carefully
considering the issue
can we i can pick that up with lord
horum um and you say you don't see what
would be gained by a meeting to discuss
this issue further
and now
as that refers to mr marshall had first
written in september 1995
and i'd just take you to a letter mr
marshall wrote to aleister goodlatte the
chief whip cabo 607 underscore zero zero
two
so this is the 10th of january 1996. so
it's a couple of weeks or so before you
you wrote your letter
and and mr marshall says this to the
chief whip
um picking it up in the third line i
find it unacceptable that i should have
had to wait over three months and not
yet received a reply to my letter asking
for a meeting between me the prime
minister and three members of the 1992
executive and a former minister to
discuss the issue of possible payment to
hemophiliacs infected with hepatitis c
if this were to be limited to those who
developed cirrhosis of the liver the
cost would be relatively slight but many
would feel a fundamental injustice has
been corrected
it is quite clear that the government is
not interested in my views on this
subject
and therefore i therefore feel i have no
alternative but to indicate i will not
be able to support the government in a
division should this issue become the
subject of a parliamentary vote
do you have any
observation on on mr martial's assertion
there that it was quite clear that the
government was not interested in his
views wasn't the question that i'm not
interested they didn't agree
and i think there's a distinction
between those two points
and it's plainly the case from the
letter you sho you read out a moment ago
neither of which incidentally had i seen
until now
that john horam had been considering the
matter that there had been discussions
that he had talked to the chief whip
about the about the matter as a whole
so he certainly wasn't being ignored and
indeed he wasn't because as we have seen
earlier i had met his delegation and
replied the letters of his
on a number of occasions in the past
that there was nothing more fresh that i
could say to him
i i should add that
this is a very important issue obviously
but
barely a day goes by when there isn't a
delegation wishing to see the prime
minister for one reason or another
and
if you accepted every delegation when
you had nothing fresh to say
and when the delegation knew what it was
you were going to say because it had
already been said to them
either by a junior minister or perhaps
on this occasion even by the chief whip
or very possibly in private
conversations in the lobby for
certainly i had conversations with those
five members not collectively but
individually
during times when we were voting
it would have been a meeting without
real purpose at that time
i had no evidence to change my mind from
the work that john horum and others were
doing
the government had set out its position
it would have simply either raised hopes
that did not exist
or it was a meeting that the delegation
wished just to indicate they had taken
things as far as they possibly could to
those who were pressing them to do so
what their motivation was i don't know
but the
outcome of it
would not have been productive at the
time they were asking for it because at
this stage i didn't know what any
conclusions were from the meetings john
horam
had been having
um no i won't take you to it but again
in the interest of fairness and for the
sake of completeness the secretary of
state for health did have a meeting with
john marshall a little later in 1996 on
the 24th of april 96.
the reference but we don't need to put
it up lawrence is dhsc zero zero four
two two eight nine underscore one
four
four uh and that was with stephen
dorrell
and
there are just two further documents i
think on this
issue
the first is dhsc
zero zero zero
four underscore 163
so this is a letter of the 29th of april
1996 and it's from mr marshall to you
and we can see in the second paragraph
it refers to the meeting that i've just
referred to his recent meeting and with
stephen durrell and so having had that
meeting mr marshall's raising the issue
with you again fourth paragraph he says
i believe the government should
re-examine this issue i accept that the
department of health budget is already
stretched and that any help has to come
from the contingency fund
and then um he sets out a suggested
estimate of of how much it would cost
he then identifies two um two other
possible ways of of
securing assistance in the penultimate
two paragraphs
in the united states several
international drugs companies such as
bayer have agreed to fund a settlement
for hemophiliacs i was wondering if they
might be persuaded to fund part of a
settlement in the uk
so that's the first suggestion could
pharmaceutical companies contribute to
some kind of fund
and then the second is this the national
lottery has far exceeded our original
expectations
would there be any possibility of the
charities board of the lottery helping
with any settlement
and then over the page
he refers then to the tribunal establish
an island
and then the last paragraph and he he
asks you to re-examine the issue
um now i think it's fair to say that
that in the remaining part of your
premiership you didn't re-examine the
issue yourself
um but i it's the
point about the national lottery i
wanted to pick up with you if we could
look first of all at your response to
that letter
hsoc0014325
and this is a letter 16th of may 1996
from you
to mr marshall
um
uh
if we go
to the third paragraph festival we can
see you refer to the irish scheme
and
the provision of
assistance in other ways other than
through financial support
last paragraph on this page you refer to
the possibility of a commercial company
you say you don't think it would be
appropriate for us to explore that
and then over the page you say this
you ask whether the national lottery
charities board may be able to fund a
settlement the nlcb makes its decisions
on applications for lottery funds
independently of the government i cannot
direct the board to fund a particular
product project however you may be
interested to know that the board is
encouraging applications from charities
working in the fields of health
disability and care in its current
funding round it is therefore possible
that hemophiliacs and those suffering
from hepatitis c might be able to
benefit from lottery grants but this
will be a matter for the board to decide
in response to any applications received
and now
um
do you have any observation or comment
on the suggestion
that you're making here about the
possibility of going to the lottery
board
well i didn't make the suggestion the
suggestion was made to me by john
marshall
but uh
this letter did get an airing at the
opening of this uh inquiry some time ago
when someone
on behalf of the plaintiffs
argued that the government
they didn't put it in these words but
the impression given that here was a
callous government telling people in
difficulties just to go to the national
lottery board and ask for help
which was a complete
misrepresentation because they had
obviously read my letter but not read
the fact that i was responding to a
specific question about the national
lottery it would not have occurred to me
to say that this isn't a matter for the
government either the government should
have paid or made a decision not to pay
but i certainly wouldn't have said
go off and ask the national lottery to
help
which was the impression given
by someone at the start of this
inquiry
so long ago i don't recall who it was
but i recall it made quite a splash at
the time which why it fixes it in my
mind
and caused me to go back at the time and
look at what i actually said and what i
actually said as you have just read was
a direct response to a request from
someone acting in the interests
of the victims
to find out whether the national
lottery's board could help and of course
it could
but the whole purpose of the lottery is
it is utterly independent of the
government
i created quite a fuss when a subsequent
government
took over control of path of the lottery
for a period because it was meant to
deal with good causes for things that
governments hadn't funded
so
i'm afraid
what was said at the outset of this was
a distortion
of the real position
but in terms of the government's own
position if we look at hsoc0026600
and this moves us all into october 1996
now i'm
skipping over some of the documents
and this is you to
um alf morris mp
um again there's been a request for you
to meet a deputation to discuss the
provision of financial assistance
um and
as again this will be picked up with
john horham on wednesday
but you essentially
maintain the same line
as this writes to john
that
there was a clear distinction between
the plight of those who contracted hiv
and those infected with hepatitis c i
did spend some time thinking about the
letter from elf morris
um upon this issue he was a very senior
and very respected member of the house
of commons
and i didn't decline a meeting just
casually
i did so because for the same reason as
i declined to meet some of my own
colleagues and that was that i had
nothing to say
that hadn't already been said and there
was nothing really to say to me that
hadn't already been put to me
i had a lot of respect for elf i didn't
like saying no he had a big heart and he
cared and he was a significant member of
parliament
but he did not have to control
government spending he did not have to
compare what we did here with other
cases in different spheres across
government so i declined a meeting
and we can take that down thank you
lawrence
it it might be said that
the approach taken by the government
focused on attempting to
distinguish the position of those
suffering from hiv
from those suffering with hepatitis c
rather than focusing on similar features
both infected in the same way from the
same products with conditions that would
be could be debilitating and lead to
death
and that might then give rise to a
recognition of the need to provide
financial assistance do you have any
comment on that
i can see why people would think that
i think it's a perfectly reasonable
assumption i don't think that's the way
we approached it
but i can see that it could be portrayed
to look that way certainly
just
more generally stepping back and looking
at the just
having in mind the decision-making that
we've explored sir john in relation
first of all to the provision of
financial assistance for those
uh hemophiliacs infected with hiv
then the provision of financial
assistance to the non-hemophiliacs
infected with hiv and then the refusal
of financial assistance to those
hemophiliacs or others
infected with hepatitis c
it might
be said that the government
became too fixated on holding the line
maintaining the ring fence
and lost sight of the
the desperate circumstances of those
whose lives had been and were continuing
to be devastated as a result of their
treatment by the nhs yes i can see that
i can see that point which is why i
said you earlier
that i looked back on this subsequently
and wasn't entirely right sure that we
had taken the right decision
clearly it wasn't comparable
to those suffering to the hemophiliacs
or hemophiliacs with hiv
it wasn't comparable to that in size or
scope
but every life is individual
and so i i can see that argument and
i'm not entirely sure in perspective
retrospect that we took the right
decision then and i was quite pleased
when
a subsequent government took a different
view
and now i want to
i i should just say um when i submit in
my written inquiry
i thought about it after i'd submitted
it
and i didn't say in that inquiry that i
i thought i perhaps might have taken all
the government might perhaps have taken
a different view i i didn't say that in
my written assessment but when i went
over what i had sent to you and went
over the documents again and again as
one does before coming to a meeting like
this which is
so important to get things right
it was as i went over those things in
retrospect
that i began to wonder whether we had
made the right decision over hepatitis c
i just want to pick up now on something
you said in your statement
and which you alluded to in your your
evidence this morning and i said i'd
come back to
it's witn 5284
and if we could go to page 13 please
lawrence
and it's paragraph
3.41 so it's the second paragraph
and you said in your statement this sir
john no one was resistant in principle
to helping the hemophiliacs he'd been
dealt an awful blow through fate
it was sheer bad luck
and you use the term bad luck again this
morning
and there was a reaction from those
those listening
the use of the phrases
fate sheer bad luck
might
suggest
thinking on your part on the
government's part that
this was
inevitable entirely unavoidable
um
was it the was it your view at the time
that the government at the time this was
just a matter of background i'm glad you
came back to that because
let me try and put things in some
context
the
problem began in the 1970s
before i was in parliament
the problem of factor eight had been
recognized and i think largely dealt
with before i became a minister
so i was looking back through the avenue
of years
and i had in mind the fact that when
this first happened unless somebody was
being completely maligned
it was a lack of scientific knowledge of
what people were doing that ensured that
people were fed disinfected blood that
was what i was trying to get now it may
be
my choice of words was
less clear-cut than they should be
but what i was attempting to say was
that
so far as i was aware
it wasn't deliberate mouthfeed
malfeasance
and the choice the victim was entirely
random
whether it had been
me in the 1970s or somebody else in the
1970s it could have been either us it
was completely random who was affected
and that was what i meant when i was if
i'd said it was completely random rather
than it was bad luck it probably
wouldn't have attracted the response it
did and it would probably have been a
fairer
illustration of what i had in mind
that i think leads to the next topic i
wanted to ask you about which is
um the question of of lack of public
inquiry
um during the time you were involved in
government during the time you were you
were prime minister um
you've said in your statement so we can
take that down thank you lawrence you've
said in your statement that the issue of
having a public inquiry was not one
raised with you or to your knowledge
considered within government
and
i think there's
just one document i've been asked to
refer you to
which i
should do so i think
which is hsoc0004580
and so this is a letter from mrs
thatcher to alf morris 4th of june 1990
um and it thanks
him for
the letter in closing one from david
watts asking for a special inquiry into
the hemophiliac claim for compensation
and then there's a discussion about
thalidomide um
and whether that was an act a comparison
or whether or not precedent but there is
there a reference to
some form of inquiry and there is a
reference that creeps in from time to
time i think in some of mr marshall's or
mr morris's communications at least an
inquiry into compensation
um
now
how would you expect the issue of the
holding of a public inquiry
to to to come about would that be
something that would
only happen in response to
an invitation or campaigning
or is it something that the government
should consider of its own initiative
well if the government considered
everything it did in a public inquiry
it would be rather
a heavy burden to undertake for everyone
i think the way they normally come about
is when the prime minister of the day
is approached and encourage and and uh
requested either by the people who seek
it or by people lobbying on their behalf
and the case is made to him or her that
there should be a public inquiry
no such case was made to me
to the best of my recollection
it was not mentioned to me at any stage
and since most of the time i was prime
minister we were actually in the
business of dealing with the problem of
hemophiliacs and providing compensation
or hiv sufferers and providing
compensation and blood and tissue
sufferers and providing compensation
the issue itself
didn't arise
and it certainly didn't arise nor was i
at that time aware that other countries
had public inquiries
and none of those public inquiries
reported during the time i was in
government
so it really was
because we were actively involved in it
for most of the time
simply not not an issue that arose
nobody mentioned it to me from within
the department of health who might have
done or from the treasury who might have
done or from the hemophilia society who
were more likely to have done it
so i was never called upon to consider
the issue
and since i considered it most of the
time
until the very end of my time in
government
the last 18 months
also um i didn't
consider it myself
without a request to do so i had no
request to do so
and so i didn't consider it i thought we
were actively dealing with the matter
and it was only like later in retrospect
in fact very many years later
that the decision 20 years after i left
office in fact
before it was decided there should be a
public inquiry
and
you've you've been provided with some
material for the purposes of your
evidence today which in refers to
uh issue of an apology by the government
of japan and then
a committee of inquiry in the united
states so is it right to understand from
your
uh your evidence a few moments ago
those matters were not matters that were
drawn to your attention
no i think uh
i think they were after i left office
and i certainly wasn't aware of them
after i left office
i i think those particular ones i've
mentioned were during your time in
office the best of my knowledge
to me
and
there were i think
a range of public inquiries some
statutory non-statutory that that
took place in the course of the 1990s
was there any formal
guidance or policy or criteria within
government in the 90s as to the
circumstances which might trigger a
decision to hold no no no no
none that i'm aware of in the 90s i'd
rather fancy i would have been aware of
them
can i then ask you to look um at
bse i
five zeros one four please
so this is your witness statement to the
bse inquiry
um date um sixth of uh may 1999 now i'm
not going to go through the the the the
the detail of this or or indeed trust us
upon the territory of the bse inquiry
but there were just a couple of passages
i wanted to ask you about as a
springboard for some more general
questions so john so if we go to the
second page
paragraph five
you say this in paragraph five
the policy of the government
consistently applied
was to act upon the advice that the
expert scientist had commissioned
provided to it
to ensure that all appropriate steps
were taken to protect the health of the
public
prevent the spread of the disease and
eradicate the disease
beyond this the government had three
further important tasks and i'm
not going to ask you about the second or
third of them but the first is to
provide information to the public
concerning the risks and incidents of
the disease
now as i say i'm not asking you about
bse
um at all but but more generally what's
what's set out there and
was it
part of the role of government
um
as far as you were concerned both in the
1990s and the 1980s when you were
for at least a significant part of the
time a member of the government
to ensure that all appropriate steps
would be taken to protect the health of
the public as a general
aim and policy
well i think that is one of the purposes
of the department of health
and then
it would appear here that you regarded
at least in the context of bsc it being
an important task for the government
to provide information to the public
concerning the risks and incidents of
the disease
would you expect that again to be
something that was part of the role of
the department of health
always to provide
in
information to the public regarding
public health risks well it depends how
what what sort of public health risks
you're thinking of if you're thinking of
a public health risk that is actually
current at the time like covid for
example
or indeed like bse
then yes because you're in the business
of preventing it getting worse
um with the question of a public inquiry
and things over the
uh the dreadful problems with blood we
were actually doing it after the event
so i think there is a distinction there
to be drawn
and uh i think i would draw that
distinction
my remarks here
were relating to the fact
uh of the particular circumstances of
bse where in fact we got into enormous
trouble by providing information to the
public
because
by providing information to the public
we weren't thanked for providing the
information
were we were denounced for apparently
causing a public health scare
and
you could argue that case either way if
we had kept quiet and said nothing we
would have been told we were
deliberately trying to hide away a real
public health risk
on the other hand if we told the public
about it
we found ourselves in a position of
being accused on all sides of creating a
public health scare by doing so
so there's a difficult balance to be
kept there and it was it was that
balance
that would have been in my mind when i
wrote
the first of those three
tasks for the government
i'm going to ask you a hypothetical
again and sir john
and
looking at the general observations you
make here but then thinking about the
1980s and eight and i i i
the question does not expect you to
have any specific knowledge of what the
department did or didn't know
but if it was
um
known to the department if it was known
to the department of health
that
there was a risk of aids
being transmitted through blood products
or blood
would you expect it to be part of the
role of the department of health to
take steps to ensure that that risk was
was known to clinicians and disseminated
to the public and to
patients well i'd like to know a little
more about that question
because i can see
ways in which my answer would be used in
a way that i wouldn't necessarily wish
it to be used
can i pitch it a different way then and
pick up on
what's a topic you deal with later in
your bsc statement which is about
openness
openness transparency
and
in the time you were in government so
from 1985 through to
1997
um
do you have any particular recollection
of what if any importance was attached
by the government of the day
to principles of openness and
transparency well i think in terms of
hiv is a good example
i think once norman fowler got
a responsibility for the subject
he was very open very productive and has
remained so ever since indeed i think
from memory he's written a few books
about it as well
so i i think he was certainly determined
to be
open about it
but there's also that risk of creating a
scare if something is contained
and you refer to it generally
and that's why i don't want to
be too
specific without knowing the full
context of the question
um
can i then we can take that down thank
you then just really
ask you
a handful of final questions
which
again are looking at government and
government decision making in in in
general
um
in your experience
and this question
invites you to reflect not just on your
time in government but your your time
in politics and looking back at politics
in your experience how good are
governments
at acknowledging
that things have gone wrong
oh i don't think they're very good at
all
and i don't think
i can go back at any stage in history
where they were
so now i don't think they're
particularly good at acknowledging uh
and acknowledging errors made
and
in terms of
the ability for governments to learn
from
errors
to undergo a period of reflective
learning
how how good are governments at that and
is there any way you can think of that
it largely depends on historic memory
if you have a time
when politicians leave politics early
they get in they become a minister for a
short time they cease to be a minister
they leave politics
or if you have a time when there is a
turnover of civil servants
toward the end of their career when they
go off and work in the private sector
then you lose historic memory
and
that loses the lessons that are learned
nobody is more valuable in a cabinet
or in a committee of the cabinet whether
it includes civil servants or not
then someone who can say i remember x
and we should learn from what happened
in this even though it was 25 or 30
years ago because we tried something and
it didn't work
now everybody in this room will no doubt
have noticed occasions where governments
have gone back to do something that a
predecessor government has tried and
failed and they've tried again and
failed again
and i think that is the loss of historic
memory
it's also partly the way in which
governments change from one side of the
political divide to the other
where a different view is taken and
perhaps
governments don't look back quite so
carefully
at what happened when their opponents
were in office
except perhaps to draw attention to the
things that go wrong
and that is a loss to the historic
memory
and that is something i think that is
very valuable nothing is more valuable
than the
quite senior person
who has been around a very long time
either in the department or in politics
and who remembers
what happens after you do something or
what happens after something is done
they can save governments from an awful
lot of trouble
um
and
leaving aside any question of what could
or should have been disseminated by the
department of health so i'm
not not going back to my earlier
question to you which you um explained
why you were
cautious about answering but but more
generally
what do you think the role of
of candor of transparency of
of
admitting to mistakes
should be for government
if i can take candor and transparency
at the time
there is always the problem there of
causing panic or setting other things
running
that is a genuine problem for all
governments
canada in retrospect i think is very
important
because there are lessons to be learned
from it
but there are some occasions in
government
when for good and sound reasons maybe to
do with public security may be to do
with public health it may be to do with
something else
when governments are bound
to dissimulate a little
at the time
and do for reasons that are
understandable even though it doesn't
meet the the pure milk
of absolute public frankness at the time
but some there are there are occasions
when absolute frankness at the time can
cause more damage than good
where you can be frank
i mean no doubt that you should be
and i think in particular you should be
to the house of commons because our
system doesn't work if government
ministers aren't frank
and honest to the house of commons and
that is extremely important that is why
i go back to your bse inquiry
we have because this illustrates the
point i'm
trying to make
we had been advised by the scientists
for a long time
that
bse could not translate to humans as cjd
it cannot happen we were told time and
time again and then it did happen
and stephen doral came to see me
the same day he heard it happened in the
morning and we had a debate what should
we do would it cause a public panic if
we went to the house of commons and said
this
or would we be accused of
hiding a scandal
if we didn't
and we decided that stephen should go to
the house of commons and be absolutely
frank about what happened which he did i
think from retrospect that same
afternoon
and it did certainly cause a great
public panic
and that is sometimes what frankness can
do
so i i just mentioned that to say that
governments aren't necessarily rogues or
hiding things because they're not
entirely frank at the moment some things
happen
but in retrospect i think they do have
to be frank when they can
so
that that
is the conclusion of the questions i was
proposing to ask so john um which i
think times nicely with the need for a
break and then core participants through
their legal representatives can suggest
any any further lines of question that
they would like me to consider
how long do you think you might need
um can i suggest if we take a little
longer than normal if we go to four
o'clock
that should give me sufficient time yes
let me let me explain um
core participants have a right in a
public inquiry to put questions through
council
um to you they will be some of them will
will be here through their uh re
recognized legal representatives that is
some of them will be here
and some of them will be watching online
and they all have a right
plainly it's right which can't sensibly
be exercised until they've heard what
you've said in answer to the questions
thus far because there may be questions
that have already been covered during
the course of the day
to give them a proper opportunity
we will not meet again until at least
four i say not before four o'clock just
in case
it goes on any longer
um
i don't know how long we should be after
that
um will be as long as the questioning
takes
four o'clock
so john just a few further questions
they won't follow a particular thematic
or chronological sequence because
they've been suggested from a range of
different different sources so
we'll dot around from topic to topic
um
the first is about the settlement of the
hiv litigation so we're talking here
late 1919
um did the settlement of the hiv
litigation have any effect as far as you
are aware on the budgets of the
territorial departments
let me think about that i think the
money was met out of the reserve in
which case no
if it had been met out of the
normal provisions of the
health authority of their health
department i think the answer is also no
because they would get a proportionate
portion of the sum total of expenditure
of those departments so i think the
answer to that is no
next question i'd asked you about the
um to some extent about the obligations
on ministers to be candid open
is there a responsibility and obligation
on civil servants to be full and frank
with the ministers in the advice that
they give yes
um
next questions about public inquiry not
about your own decision making but about
the decision to um establish this
inquiry
was that something that was discussed
with you in advance by the then prime
minister theresa may
the next question is about
the issue of no fault compensation
would you agree
that insisting on victims proving fault
establishing legal liability may get in
the way of lessons being learned
well i think a new um
a new precedent has been established now
of x grasha payments
so i don't think you can get away from
the danger of no fault compensation
but there's now been a way to go around
it
and deal with cases where there is
a special requirement
because of an event
that may not have been the direct fault
of a government or government's
servants in any capacity
but where compensation
is
is merited
and i think the ex gratia payment uh
proposal
that uh that was developed will meet
that in future
and now
um a number of the documents we've
looked at have used the the term
compensation
and
i think i may well have used it in my
questions to you you you've used the the
term in your answers
um
at the time you were taking decisions or
involved in decision making late 80s
through the 90s did you understand there
to be a difference between
compensation as properly understood
compensating for the injury that someone
has suffered and the loss they've
suffered
and the provision of financial support
or assistance which is
less than compensatory
well there's two aspects of that
um
the first one is the
is the social security
payments
which uh
plainly stand on their own quite apart
from the que i think compensation is the
wrong word actually excrucia payments
would be a more accurate way it isn't
compensation compensation in terms of
you cannot compensate
there is no way you can compensate for
what happened to the victims
of the blood tragedy you cannot
compensate wouldn't matter whatever you
did for them or or
paid them there is no compensation for
the way their lives were wrecked let's
be entirely clear about that so i think
compensation isn't the right term
an excretion payment is probably
a more accurate way but i'm i'm i'm not
sure that there's a word that you
couldn't take offence to if you wish to
it's a but it certainly hasn't
compensation which these days has also
come to be used as
a narrative for salary as well your
compensation for doing your job is
x pounds a year
so certainly we should get away from the
use of the word compensation because it
doesn't and it can't
now
one of the
themes of the decision-making that we've
looked at was the government's desire to
avoid setting a precedent
and
is the
the answer or an answer to that concern
about setting a precedent
and to investigate
what happened and how it happened and
take steps to prevent that happening
again
rather than just saying well we can't
set a precedent so we won't provide
financials yes it could be but it would
delay it
i mean if we had decided that until we'd
found out and had an inquiry like this
to determine exactly what had happened
nobody would have received anything
until now
so you actually that the payments were
needed when they were needed they were
not needed in retrospect and in the case
of many of the early victims of this
they're no longer here sadly to receive
a payment compensation call it what you
will so i think there is a need to act
uh quickly certainly there are lessons
to be learned
and no doubt will be learned as a result
of this
a very extensive inquiry
and i suppose those lessons will spread
into a whole series of different areas
um
i next wanted to ask you about
an answer you gave in your in your
statement i don't think we need to look
it up but you were asked
um in your statement what influence the
the
forthcoming general election in 1992 had
on policy making or decision making
regarding the financial support
or the provision of financial support or
non-provision of financial support um
what what is your position in relation
to that well it didn't i mean the things
that were
in uh in trade at the time of the
election
were the maastricht agreement
which had been
wildly well received when first made and
subsequently came under huge criticism
particularly from within the
conservative party
and that produced a divided party and
and and was a significant issue then
there was the question of rising
inflation
falling house prices and the other
economic problems that arose from events
in the 80s but carried a recession right
into the early years of the 90s and
those were those were the mega issues of
the uh
of the campaign
and uh uh
i i can honestly say the the decision on
compensation on a payment
at that stage
was not affected by the
forthcoming general election and did not
affect the election
in any material way
what percentage of the overall treasury
budget is the contingency reserve or was
the contingency reserve in broad terms
oh god i can't tell you i mean i mean
it's
i think i said it was an a lot a science
so it isn't a fixed percentage of the
overall budget
it's an assessment
of uh
of what is judged
you don't exactly lick your finger and
hold it in the air to
decide but it's certainly not a
scientific examination it's
it's a guesstimate of what might be
needed
um
what's your understanding of what should
happen to a departmental minister's
private office papers
when they leave post or move to a
different post
is your expectation maybe i'm not sure
what is meant by private papers because
the papers belong to the government
so i'm not sure what is meant in that
question by private papers to the best
of my knowledge
civil servants do not have private but i
suppose they can write their own private
diary
um and that i assume would remain
private but they have no private papers
within the department
the papers that they write and the
papers that they receive
are departmental papers and they go into
the official records so the um
let me put it a different way and it's a
question i'm asking on behalf of someone
so this is my own paraphrasing of it a
minister's private office papers
um
uh
um what should happen to those oh
they're the same they're in the archives
that's where the papers that uh
the inquiry provided to me came from
they came from
the archives that the government hold
collectively of what has happened in
individual departments over the years
and i mean to make the point clear
they are not papers that belong to the
individual minister that can be
destroyed if that is what lies
underneath the question it is i think
i think it is too uh the the papers
belong to the government and they are
public papers
and one of the things that have changed
of course from the 80s
in the 1980s
ministers and officials
might scribble notes on the paper
now those notes at those time weren't
going to be released for 50 years
so sometimes they were incredibly frank
and sometimes rather rude
take no notice of this the man's an
idiot for example you might find written
on some of them
now of course that's very useful to
historians in the long term because they
actually get a practical picture of what
is going on
i'm not sure
that now public papers are released so
much more speedily
that
that happens
certainly in some governments
after mine
notes such as that were written on
little pieces of yellow paper that were
stuck to the papers and then removed
subsequently
and that's a loss to history
and
i asked you a few minutes ago about the
obligation of the civil servant to be
frank and
and comprehensive and the advice
provided to to ministers
if
briefings are given which subsequently
uh come to the attention whether of the
same a series of civil servants or later
ones were were incomplete or potentially
inaccurate or misleading
would you expect
the civil servants who have appreciated
that to bring that to the attention of
ministers
i think they would write a replacement
minute
they'd probably be very discreet and say
circumstances have changed therefore
misunderstanding the position is x and
i certainly wouldn't expect a mistaken
brief to be re-echoed in subsequent
briefs so you would expect in some form
or another the mistake to be corrected
yes i would
just as mistakes made in parliament
uh should be corrected
if parliament is misinformed by a
minister
uh it should be corrected
and then um
last question on on this topic
we
seen through some of the documents that
we've looked at
how
a line to take is
is repeated from minister to minister
civil service civil servant civil
servant potentially from one
administration to to another
um
does that risk
policies decisions
um
simply continuing almost through a
process of inertia or rapidly the answer
to that question is yes it can do
and and i think you have to realize what
the briefings are the briefings are a
background for ministers
they're not an instruction to ministers
to stick to them
now often there is something
that is so seared into the blood as it
were
that i'm sorry that was a bad analogy
it's so seared into the mind
that uh
it takes quite a lot to to
shift it out and change course
and i think you could perhaps argue that
case over over no fault compensation
um
but uh
but briefs are that they are briefs and
and the briefs from
from civil servants are factual
i mean you asked me earlier today and i
wasn't quite sure
how to how to explain the point properly
how repeatedly
there were minutes saying governments
can take credit for this or take credit
for that
and that sounds pretty awful and it did
sound pretty awful when you said it but
of course it's the state was this it
wasn't is the style of minutes i mean we
are talking
of a different age
in terms of emoting
between now and the 1980s and early
1990s and
2022
this is the age of let it all hang out
it certainly wasn't the age of let all
your emotions hang out in the 80s and
90s indeed quite the reverse
and i think that was reflected a bit in
some of the
apparently insensitive minutes
where i knew i had had discussions with
ministers who were concerned about
something
but the minutes that appeared did not
seem to back that up
and and i think that is probably
that is probably why why that happened
and then just going back to this issue
of
of there being an
inertia potentially if a line to take or
policy is simply simply repeated
to what extent is it the role
either of ministers or of
perhaps more senior civil servants to
um to challenge the status quo to probe
to ask if there is a different
perspective that should now be because
it is with senior civil servants but
senior civil servants will probably go
and see the minister rather than write a
note to the minister and say you have
made a complete muck-up of this we
should be doing it differently they will
probably go and see them and talk to
them and say have you considered this
this is a problem this isn't going to
run we've seen this before it doesn't
work
and actually you saw an illustration of
that this morning
william chapman
in my private office and number 10
was not a permanent secretary
but you don't get to be one of the
handful of
secretaries in the prime minister's
office
unless you've got an exceedingly good
brain
you are independent
and you are in civil service terms a
high flyer if you're in the prime
minister's private office you can expect
to rise very high
in the civil service over the years to
uh to come indeed jeremy hayward from
whom he saw notes became cabinet
secretary
and you saw in william chapman
a straightforward urge to change policy
now had he discussed that with me before
he put it all down on paper
possibly not directly in saying i want
to say this that or the other but he had
probably chatted through the policy
casually with me and then put down a
note
reflecting what had happened and his own
views of what should happen so there was
a practical case
of an independent-minded high-quality
civil servant
saying discreetly to the government
you may have got this wrong
it's time to move on and that is a
legitimate role
but it is something that really can only
be done by
civil servants
close to the prime minister or the
minister
or very senior civil servants
they can say to ministers and should you
have got something wrong there is no one
more valuable in your private office
than someone who will act as devil's
advocate and say
don't do it it's a mistake
and i just want to go back to something
i asked you a few minutes ago about
about
whether investigating how things had
gone how things had happened
and taking steps to prevent them
happening again might be
a a way of
avoiding
the problem about precedence
and i think one the answer you gave in
part at least was to say well that would
build in delay
and
can i just
suggest to you it wouldn't necessarily
build in delay because there's nothing
to stop a government doing both at the
same time is they're making
an ex gracia payment to deal with
immediate financial need for example and
doing so quickly
but then taking steps to work out what
what happened
put in place any any appropriate
measures to prevent it happening again
and
and drawing some comfort from that that
they both avoided
the the
um
risks of it happening again and and
potentially prevented other people from
yeah of course of course that could
happen i mean you heard me in answer to
one question i forget which one it was
but uh you asked me a hypothetical
question and i said in those
hypothetical circumstances i would go
back and ask for more information now
that's an illustration of doing the sort
of thing you're referring to
what i was referring to my answer is you
couldn't have a comprehensive
investigation like this
because even if it had been set in train
in 1995
it would have taken
some years probably to report to learn
all the lessons but where you can see
more intrinsic or more minor things
going wrong yes of course you can do
that by a re-examination
and that is relatively routine
and so those are the questions i have
i'm just going to check with mr murray
has anything no
um do you have any questions for
suggestions
yes i i do um
they all arise out of things that you've
said during the the course of your your
oral evidence
um and they
the first uh
was just before lunch she was talking
about
settlement and you spoke of and your
words were the legitimate claim
legitimate claim for help
from the hemophiliacs who had been
damaged by infected blood
now plainly that was you're using the
word legitimate
words legitimate claim now was that the
way you saw it at the time
well i think you saw in the evidence i
gave this morning
that whenever i was approached
i without dissent
conceded
two payments being made team of philips
with the exception of the uh
uh of
the last uh the last occasion
um
and i did think they had a good case
whether i would use the word legitimate
or not i'm not sure
i think they suffered and well
it was right
for the state to offer assistance to
them i think i would prefer to put it
that way
it brings me
really to
just as two aspects of what you you said
that were perhaps intriguing um
you were
asked earlier this morning
um
about something that john muir said
uh and you said this that
john moore had said at one stage
there was not a good
case for compensation for reasons of
precedent he did not rule out
nor did he say he'd rule out
compensation in view of the
circumstances
of those who were infected
can i just
look with you for a moment at the
question of precedent
and how it interacts with special
circumstances
precedent i suppose involves two things
one may be
looking back to the past
and seeing if it's been done before
or not been done before so there's a
precedent either for doing it
or not doing it it may also be a fear
for establishing by doing it for the
first time as you may think
that it may happen again and there may
be a call for it to happen again and so
he may be establishing a precedent for
the future there's two sides
but in in either case however one views
precedent
it only applies doesn't it if the facts
in each case are sufficiently similar
for the principle which underlies them
to apply to both cases well it was the
principle that was concerning the
government
the principle that unless there had been
shown to be
a a legal requirement to pay
because of misbehavior in some form by
by the government agency
then there had been no occasion when
there had been compensation
and
the reference to no fault compensation
was based on the principle that that had
never happened before we governments
collectively of all parties as far back
as one could trace
had never agreed in the principle of no
fault compensation if the government had
made a failure either they agreed
compensation or it went to court and
they were forced to pay compensation
but to pay compensation without having
found to be at fault and without having
gone to court had not happened before
and it was that principle which we
loosely called no fault compensation
that uh was
an inherent part of the instincts of the
treasury in particular
but also across government
how do
special circumstances then affect it
presumably
it may be that if there are special
circumstances for instance a land slip
at abba fan
um
the vaccine damage
things of that sort which
um
are not
simply
things that happen they happen to such
an extent into so many people that they
require the state to take some form of
of action uh however one uses the word
require i just mean it in general terms
um
if you can
identify particular circumstances then
it doesn't become no fault compensation
does it
no it doesn't if you can if you can
identify those circumstances
uh but at the time
there was no scientific knowledge that
what was being done in the 70s which was
plainly wrong and caused terrible
tragedies that it was not known to
anybody there was nothing anyone could
have done
that would have prevented it in the
light of what was known by science and
medicine at that time
now that's not the case in aberfan
plainly they shouldn't have banked up
everything that fell down on aberfan in
the 1960s and so on so you could find
a fault and something that could and
should have been prevented
with
uh the lack of knowledge when someone
was doing something for which there was
no knowledge that it went wrong it was
done for the best of motives but it was
wrong
then nobody could have foreseen that
nobody was derelict in their
responsibilities
and that really is the point that
underlies
the no-fault compensation argument
it may be that you have the the same
answer the second exchange which really
um caught my my ear
and it was in relation to when you were
looked at you looked at
a document i wonder if lawrence you can
put it up
hmtr
six zeros one
underscore zero one two
it's the letter from paul gray or the
number 10 at number 10 of the 20th of
november 1989.
and it's the second page
and there
if one looks at the point number one
talking about the discussion which has
been held i appreciate you weren't part
of this discussion but you were asked
about this
in relation to government decision
making
and the
what mr gray is saying that the
point as he records it
is in presenting that such a package it
will be desirable
as and he's talking about the 20 million
extra pounds that
this was
as well as avoiding any acceptance of
legal liability to avoid conceding any
moral obligation
so it's payment without legal obligation
it's been without moral obligation
and
you were asked about that and you say
well
problem with moral obligation is anyone
can find a moral obligation for anything
uh and you've created a precedent
uh and you be well
actual words i'm sorry i'm i'm i'm
summarizing it obviously i've got it
wrong it's a very free interpretation
well because as was apparent from my
later answers i thought there was a
moral obligation
so had paul grey directed that to me i
might have uh sent it back and asked him
to rephrase it
it's because otherwise it would seem
rather odd wouldn't it the government
was paying
without any obligation legal or moral
but simply because it
as it were felt like it because it was
making an ex gracious payment
so well i think you can make it i mean i
made it clear i think there was a moral
obligation thank you i i made that clear
um plainly that wasn't the view of mr
gray when he wrote that particular
minute and then maybe that wasn't agree
uh the the broad opinion at that time in
government i think there was but i i i
think at the time of that government
they would still have made a payment
because it is almost impossible unless
you are completely compassion free
not to understand the sheer horror of
what happened not
only to the people who were infected
with the blood but their families
and and and and the wider implication
that would have had on a lot of people's
lives
i don't think any government would have
stood wholly away from that what they
would have done
would have tried to avoid a precedent
that could be misused
and
the risk always with this is the misuse
of precedent
and i'm sure like me you can consider
you can see you can see all sorts of
ways in which this might
a completely
free acknowledgement and moral
obligation would open all sorts of
things
do the government have a moral
obligation because they didn't know
about something and they didn't do it
well you could argue they do in every
respect
if you start conceding moral obligations
here now i think the times have changed
and we can do that
and i think the experience that we've
had since
1989
uh with the day
with the introduction of excretion
payments gives us a way around that
moral maze
but i can see that paul agree was a very
able civil servant i may say in the
prime minister's private office
at the time and previously from what i
recall
paul gray was a senior official in the
treasury
so i can quite see why he would have
phrased it that way
in the light of thinking in the 1980s
but i do not myself personally agree
with it
now you've said in in that answer that
you yourself regarded there as being a
moral obligation
uh you said earlier that you thought
that the ex-glacier principle was a way
forward if you like for
for the future
how did the two interact
well i think if you can make an
exceptional case
and plainly in this case you can
if
you seat
if you cite a legal obligation
that's a very unwise thing to do because
how can you determine it the courts may
consider differently indeed the advice
the government got repeatedly
right through the compensation packages
we produced
was that if we went to court if we were
taken to court
the balance of probabilities is that the
government would win the case
and that was repeatedly the
advice
that being said you are using public
money without a legal justification
so if you cannot have a legal
justification what is your justification
for spending the taxpayers money
and there has to be one
um i would call it a moral obligation
other people may call it something
different
but i think we have to recognize that
those circumstances will occur
and in a civilized
the majority have an obligation to a
minority if that minority falls on
particularly hard terms times the same
principle applies of course with social
security payments
there's no legal
obligation to pay a social security
payment to someone who is unemployed
but there is an obligation in a
civilized society to do so
and you can equate that
as a first cousin perhaps i might say to
what has happened with the excretion
payments in this particular case
thank you very much that's all that i
ask
so john is there anything that you wish
to add
i think i'm done
no i don't think so thank you
sir brian well i i just want to express
uh our gratitude to you sir john for
coming and giving your evidence to us
um
the measured evidence as it's been
described already uh online
your willingness to consider
the material which you've been sent and
indeed to
to reflect uh and perhaps change your
mind to the extent that you
consider that you may have got a
decision wrong in in respect of
hepatitis c
uh and for that i i think you deserve
the respect of those who've been
listening
um you've given a clear explanation of
your role
at the treasury and the prime minister
as prime minister and that's been
helpful
and how
despite being like a super tanker before
it turns
the government is often unseen but on
the move and that's valuable to
to hear from someone that was occupied
the highest positions of state such as
yourself
thank you very much thank you very much
may i just say one thing
i obviously caused offence inadvertently
this morning
when i referred to
the fact that it was awful that people
had been fed infected blood and i
referred to it as sheer bad luck i can
only say to people it wasn't intended to
be offensive
i was seeking to express the fact that i
was concerned about what happened and
what i meant was the point i raised
earlier that it by shear by like it was
a random sample there were six to 65
million people in the country in the
1970s
and 3000 people
had the
appalling
outcome of having been fed infected
infected blood so i just wanted to say
if anybody thought i was being
dismissive
or offensive
please don't think that that certainly
was not my intention
and i was rather surprised
well perhaps i'm not surprised at the
sensitivity i think if i were in the
position
of those people who either had infected
blood or whose families someone in whose
families i i would be sensitive as well
so i would just wish to say to you that
if that caused defense i apologize it
wasn't intended to do so it was intended
simply to say that it was
a random matter
and i perhaps expressed it
in judiciously and if i did i apologize
to those who were offended i think it
was an unfortunate choice of words yes
but i don't think it may be unfortunate
partly because bad luck looks as though
you're talking about cause yes i know
and
random event is looking at incidents and
they're two different things i must have
answered 500 questions today um i'm
sorry i got one
i responded to it in an inelegant way
i'm sure we will read about it tomorrow
and so moving to tomorrow we have the
evidence of virginia bottomless bottom
wall thank you very much thank you very
much indeed 10 o'clock tomorrow virginia
bottom thank you
you